foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
gag it Daddy
judge chicken
lays one on Donald Trump kicks him
straight in the sack
this morning an open court where Donald
Trump didn't appear his attorney lauro
did appear of course solaro appeared
that's
what judge checking said was going to
happen and it happened they weren't too
busy I guess
I checked and laying down several orders
this morning the news is is that this
protective order will only protect
sensitive information now so anything it
appears anything public from the select
committee or that is already made public
won't be deemed sensitive but most of
the things mostly that are not public
will be deemed sensitive they will
market and Trump's attorney Laro agrees
with a memo marking documents there's a
gazillion
a gazillion documents in discovery which
I believe is probably I would want to
say the more Discovery there is
the worse it off is it is for Grandpa
I do want to say though I told the
audience and I've been screaming and
yelling that chutkin would not go
outside the boundaries of the rule of
law and she's not
she said specifically about a circus
well
Carnival she called it
judge Judkins quote is while I intend to
ensure that Mr Trump has afforded all
the rights that any citizen should have
I also take seriously my obligation to
prevent
his so-called a carnival atmosphere of
unchecked publicity and trial by media
this case is no exception so tell me
about cameras again
stop saying it chutkin has put an end to
your stupid idea and the campaign that
there's going to be made into the
reality show of Justice there won't be
cameras in the courtroom there will be
Justice
so checkin's ruling coming down this
morning basically telling Donald Trump
hey I get that you're running for
president I get that you're in a
campaign that may be your day your day
job friend but you're also in criminal
trial and you're under criminal
indictment so you will act as if you're
a criminal defendant
now will she go as far as to hold him in
criminal contempt will she gag him
she's put a protective order on
sensitive information
that's what is coming out of this
morning
now
the other situation that is being
considered by judkin is the trial date
the thing really
important about the trial date
and I I again I I keep telling you folks
that there's a situation here that is a
federal criminal trial with a judge who
is serious about being a judge in a
federal criminal trial maybe unlike
Canon
yeah
and she's giving Trump incentive an
opportunity which defendants are
generally given
by judges
that is a thing that happens
in
Federal criminal trial where you're
technically
legally innocent until proven guilty
her quote is in addition the more a
party makes inflammatory statements
about this case which could taint to
jury pool so she's speaking to the jury
pool here and about the jury pool not
about tampering and intimidating
Witnesses she says the greatest the
greater the urgency will be that we
proceed to trial quickly
I will take whatever measure measures
are necessary to safeguard the Integrity
of these proceedings so she's telling
Donald Trump I know you want to delay
you bastard
so what I'll do is make you a deal you
keep your [__] mouth shut
and I'll give you the delays that you
want
I guarantee you I guarantee you that
Donald Trump is going to back off this
job everyone's this morning says oh he's
not going to be able to help himself
when he finds out that he is going to be
given an opportunity to delay
what do you think he's gonna do you
think he's gonna pick delay judge judge
chetkin is brilliant I told you that I
told you she was brilliant I told you
not only was is she is she a prosecutor
not only has she been working for the
government and being a Justice before
but this judge originally started her
Public Service as a public defender
which is very important in the grand
scheme of things of her career as a
federal judge
but more importantly it almost makes her
the perfect
federal judge for this specific case of
how sensitive this case is how important
it is for this case to be a criminal
trial not a reality TV show
I don't know how the universal line to
get chutkin on this case and have that
draw
and have the draw of Cannon down in
South Florida which is the worst
possible situation in that criminal case
but the criminal case in this morning in
these proceedings it is clear
that chetkin is the judge she will act
as such and she will treat him just like
any other criminal defendant that comes
to trial she will not treat him more
fairly or more unfairly than any other
person that appears before her
going forward with those facts we must
accept every single ruling that she
makes that is right we must make the
commitment seeing her words this morning
it is my pledge that I will I I will
take in stride every single ruling that
this judge makes this judge is smarter
than we know
it's not surprising seeing her
background and her experience
to be quite honest again there's no more
perfect judge in this case than her
and she will be fair to Donald Trump as
long as he abides
by the pre-trial conditions
will she jail him I seriously doubt it
and the reason why is she just gave
every single piece of rope for Donald
Trump to hang himself here
when she gives him the opportunity
to delay
and to push this trial to slow walk
if he shuts his [__] trap now will he
have the ability I guess that's the
question that we will answer in the
coming minutes hours
afternoon
we will see we will see how Grandpa
booby pants responds to this protective
order
not only is she protecting the evidence
and protecting intimidating Witnesses
but also there were some back and forth
between Trump's lawyer
and the judge judge judkin about
campaigning and about making marks about
other candidates I.E Mike Pence
Mike Pence is a witness in this case and
he is a presidential candidate at this
point it won't last long don't worry
it won't last long don't worry Mike
Pence is go nowhere there's a video out
of Iowa State Fair
where Trump supporters are still
heckling Mike Pence at every turn
and they're worse than the fly on his
head yelling and screaming that he's a
traitor
Good Luck Good Luck courting Trump cult
votes there Mike
Mike Pence won't last long but while
he's in the race shutkin has made it
clear that I understand that you are
running for president United States but
you will not
you will not intimidate witnesses will
not affect their testimony will not
affect their ability to be a witness in
this trial and will not affect the jury
pool you will not taint it
so Donald Trump has been giving his
warnings this morning and really
honestly Donald Trump couldn't ask for
anything better that happened this
morning
I I don't I don't want to to make this
feel like this is just good for the
justice system I'm telling you this
judge this judge gave every opportunity
for Donald Trump to do what he's
supposed to do
shut his [__] mouth put on a defense
and go to trial
and if you do those things then I will
give you the opportunity that you need
to delay this as long as your lawyers
need possible
we will see what a trial of the first
trial date that comes out of this
and we will see exactly and it may have
been dropped in the last several minutes
I I'm not really sure
it's unclear exactly when she'll rule on
the trial date whether it be later today
or tomorrow it doesn't appear that she's
gonna rule on it in open court
but what did happen in open court this
morning was
for Donald Trump
to abide by the protective order and not
intimidate Witnesses or release evidence
meaning sensitive and nonsensitive he
and she she made clear that he has the
freedom to speak he just does not have
the freedom to intimidate Witnesses
another another quote in that manner
by chetkin is about the the internet let
me see if I can find that one quickly uh
who here it is checking says to Laro to
Trump's attorney conflating what your
client needs so do to defend himself and
what your client wants to do politically
your client's defense is supposed to
happen inside this courtroom not on the
internet so she's clearly sending a
message to Trump and his legal team do
not do not
try to make this this case on the
internet
do not go to the internet and take to
the to the interwebs
to defend yourself you will defend
yourself in this courtroom against this
criminal matter that you have been
indicted on
so we will see
we will see exactly
uh how judge chutkin acts as
Donald Trump responds he will respond
he's going to respond to this or he'll
shut his mouth the the best case
scenario for Trump at this point is to
shut his mouth which is probably why he
won't
and we'll see if there's a gag order
because a protective order is a little
different than a gag order
right protective order is talking about
evidence and using that evidence and
using that Discovery to intimidate
Witnesses intimidate their testimony
because once Donald Trump knows exactly
what the witnesses have said and what
the witness have testified to he can try
to use that in the in an open public
forum like the internet and fraud social
to intimidate Witnesses and to Tainted
Journey pool as well
before they see the evidence
so she's warning him against that
a gag order is where he won't shut his
mouth on true social and keeps calling
people nicknames and she says you cannot
talk about this case at all
ever nowhere
which it could result in him being held
in criminal contempt which could result
in him being in a jail cell so we'll see
what Donald Trump chooses because it is
now Donald Trump's Choice it is his
choice now of what he wants to do so we
will see what Grandpa Poopypants decides
in the coming minutes
no literally I don't know as you posted
on tree socialit maybe we should check
that
maybe we should check that out but I I
hate to tell you that I told you so but
I you shouldn't doubt me that much I
told you exactly what judge chuckin
could do from her history
and what she would do in this courtroom
and what is clear that judge judkin is
not going to go outside the bounds and
rules of the law she's just not it's not
gonna happen and if for anyone out there
to be to be rather you're on Trump's
side or the prosecution side here
it is going to be very it is very clear
this morning where this where this
criminal trial and this criminal
proceedings is headed
so
that's the facts that we need to go off
of now how do we politicize this
how do we politicize this well how you
politicize this is the information that
the prosecution and the defense we're
talking about with the sensitive
information there are transcripts folks
there are transcripts in the discovery
from the January 6th select committee
that are not public
there's something in those transcripts
there's something there
there are something there
and I think this trial is going to get
to the bottom of it honestly a lot of
people have said to me privately they
hope Trump takes a deal which I think
he's well past a deal right like there's
no there's no deal that Jack Smith is
going to give at this point
besides yeah you get prison time yeah
we'll give you a deal we'll make you a
deal instead of a dirty 30 we'll we'll
give you 20. how does that sound
fatty
uh he called Chris Christie a fat pig
and Chris Christie's like get some more
[__] mirrors what do you want me to
do
I'm just going off the public discourse
that exists
[Laughter]
but Donald Trump is not going to take a
deal in this case and there's really no
deal to give him really honestly what's
the deal to give him
that he that he wouldn't have already
that he wouldn't have already sought out
in the first place
his attorneys have been have been
communicating with the special counselor
for some time on the documents case and
you have to assume on the January 6th
case
so if there was a deal to be had already
Jack Smith would have definitely making
that made that deal with Donald Trump
don't you think
whatever the deal may be maybe he slinks
away maybe goes on house I you know I
don't know I don't know what they maybe
maybe he 14s himself disqualifies
himself and drops that you know I don't
know what the deal could be
but if there was a deal then it would
have been had already
so I don't believe that there's a deal
that Jack Smith or Donald Trump could
make
we are headed towards a criminal trial
when that's a good question I actually
believe that it's probably not going to
be before the election I hope so
everyone keeps saying I I hope not for a
trial I hope for a trial I just I'm very
skeptical and what I want to do is worst
case scenario you understand that right
I want worst case scenario here worst
case scenario is he runs for president
he becomes the nominee and we have to
fight like hell to beat him and then he
goes to try and he goes to trial after
the election that's worst case scenario
for me I'm going off worst case if we if
we operate under anything other than
worst case we're doing ourselves a
political disservice
we're getting our hopes up we're relying
on Jack Smith in the Department of
Justice to save our country and that is
not their job just judge chutkin's job
is not to save democracy
she is have an oath to defend the
Justice in the court
and to bring Justice
in the court and she will do that she's
been it's clear this morning but she has
not she is not the hero of our democracy
she may be one of them in the long run
and in history we'll tell that story
but in today's and today right now in
this timeline in this moment as we are
in
we have to operate under the under under
the idea that it is us
we the people that are Trump's jury
and we we get to taint that jury pool
you understand that right that jury pool
can be tainted all to hell
we are not under jury selection
we are chosen by our constitution as one
person one vote
that is Trump's jury
that is the resounding message that this
country should send no matter what the
circumstances that play out in this
weird ass bunk timeline
and it is time we act like it every last
one of us in the pro-democracy Coalition
who want to advance democracy to get our
heads on straight and understand that
now is the time to democracy now is the
time to engage in our nation now is the
time to be vigilant against fascism it
is knocking on our front door
they are here they are not going away
either I don't know if you noticed that
we beat Trump time and time again in the
political battles
of the midterm 2020 the 2022 midterms
and now in 2024
and that battle will continue long after
that
it's going to take decades to get this
fascism
to get off our backs
but we can do it and we must do it
together
and the Coalition is growing
don't doubt that don't listen to the
media don't listen to the polls don't
listen to the banter go by your
instincts your instincts are going to be
correct
and the instinct is to work your ass off
to make sure that we have a free and
fair election and our Liberty is intact
because if we let fascism take over our
governments our Liberty is at stake we
see it in Florida we see it in other red
States
these Republicans continue to try and
use their power and use their
representation to strip away Americans
rights
we played a video yesterday of Trey
Crowder speaking of majority ruin
minority rule
and in this country we have lived under
minority rule for quite some time
it is time that the majority rule it is
time that the game is unrigged
it is time that we Grant all people the
rights and the opportunities to Liberty
now is the time that is the focus
not rather there's cameras in a
courtroom
chutkin told you no this morning
so stop
you know
stop with that nonsense
go to something that matters
what matters is us now politicizing
every single issue all the way up and
all the way down the ballot because that
is the battle that will be fought is the
ballot
and to politicize every single issue
every last one of them to make sure
that we save our democracy We the People
it is us we are the government
it is our nation it is our constitution
it is our freedom and our Liberty to
defend
and the ballot is the weapon that we use
so know this
we are with the people in Ohio
we are with the people in Kansas we are
with them in Kentucky in Wisconsin and
Montana and any other state that gets
out there to defend our rights
and we know from those instances and
those special elections that yes
Americans are the majority for Liberty
real not that fake ass Patriot Liberty
[__] we got the freedom of religion to
press our religion on you no that is not
the freedom of religion
it is freedom from religion
if we so choose
so what shall you do
what shall you do
shall you stay focused on the things
that matter I think you will and the
reason why is you come here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch don't forget to
subscribe here on YouTube it's free free
99 it didn't cost you a single nickel to
subscribe so hit the goddamn button
would you please also hit a thumbs up or
if you don't like me hit a thumbs down
am I getting better at that I think I'm
getting better at that we got a new
thing here speaking of YouTube YouTube
you know this YouTube does not like me I
don't know what to tell you they don't
like me they don't like some of the
things I say
I don't know what to tell you
I know you do they do not that's why we
have a they they will not have us in the
algorithm or the [__] that's why you got
to spread the word for us but a lot of
people have been talking for months and
months and months about Super Chat and
they want Super Chat they want Super
Chat they want a way to chat and to
support the show well this morning we
are unveiling a brand new way to do this
uh if you want you can go to venmo you
can we're going to do venmo chat you can
send me a message on venmo chat
and I will bring up your message on air
I will talk to you on air and I will
whether you want to do a question or
just a message whatever you want if I
don't get to the ones on the show I'm
going to try to do social media videos
to make sure to make sure that your your
message is seen if you want to give a
venmo chat so get in get in the venmo
chat the link is down below
they will put let's see here I'll put it
in the chat here we'll just put it in
the chat how's that sound I think the
commentators probably already have it in
there but we'll put it in there
oh that's not what I want of course oh
boy
every single time there we go there's
the venmo chat now so get to the venmo
chat you can also go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can find the venmo chat
there if you want to get on the venmo
chat and I'll keep an eye on it if you
guys post any messages over on the venmo
chat I'll get to your messages also
don't forget boy if you're not on
Discord this is where the chat party
never stops that's right the chat party
is over always over on Discord so if you
got the Discord app go to the Discord
link uh we've got the link Down Below in
the description but if you need it
if you need it in the chat here it is
right here uh we'll post it in the chat
so now now you have the venmo and the
Discord get your butt over there I'm
telling you all night all day like 24 7.
it's it's where the chat party never
stops over on Discord yes Joy leave says
the we are the party over on Discord and
your highness posting a yabba dabba doo
happy Friday to you meme over there uh
and they're they're talking back and
forth and they've been they've been
doing crochet and making bread in the
chat this morning I'm not kidding you
that's what they're doing over there in
the Discord chat so if you guys want to
party all night long uh in a Tony
Michaels chat in the [__] them fam chat
and go over to Discord the link is in
the chat now
also also don't forget you can follow us
on Twitch for free
if you have your Amazon Prime account
tied to your Twitch account make sure to
go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels and
resubscribe that way that way you get
your commercial free viewing on Twitch
and we get a couple bucks from Amazon
it's not a lot but we get a couple bucks
it's a free way to support us give us
monetary support then cost you a single
extra dime on your Amazon Prime account
if you need directions just go to the
Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you'll find
directions there you'll find all the
links
at the Tony michaels.com here let me let
me show it to you why not we got a few
minutes it's Friday we're gonna go to
bonehead of the week here at the top of
the hour I'm going to show you some of
these tweets
um of these quotes from from jetkin
and you got some more video to show you
but I want to show you that the here's
here's the Tony michaels.com I don't
know if you guys have been here uh if
you go to the Tony michaels.com that
episode that is current that is current
is always at the very top so you can
find it very easy it's the the YouTube
link there's the venmo super chat now if
you want to do a super chat get there to
venmo Super Chat and go to the Tony
michaels.com it'll take you to the link
where you can do that you can also give
a tip jar you can go to the patreon page
see what we're doing over there for
Roundtable democracy uh speaking of that
I'm going to this uh this weekend I'm
gonna set the patreon where you can you
can join for free that's right you can
join patreon for free this weekend I'll
post it on social media when I get it
all organized and and set because I
think I got to do a few things to make
it that way now but once I get it to
where you can join patreon for free and
you'll be able to go over there and
follow and you'll be able to watch
everything and see some stuff so so go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels or
download the patreon app on your phone
and go to patreon
and go to the Tony Michaels this weekend
I'll be there'll be a new free
membership it'll be free to join patreon
so remember that and there would be
still the paid memberships to give
support and get extras and extra content
and access to like the Sunday rant but
some of the content is going to be
completely free including the Roundtable
democracy which you see right here the
Roundtable democracy playlist which this
this afternoon
I haven't decided exactly what time I
think we're probably gonna do it about
two o'clock Central
so that's that's three o'clock Eastern
so about an hour after we get off the
air I'm hoping it depends on how long
bonehead the week last but about an hour
that we get off the air I'm gonna go and
we're gonna go to field team six for
Roundtable democracy we're gonna take a
tour around field Team Six
so we're going we're going to uh go
to uh the field team six and get the
round table of democracy in good shape
there and we'll have a new workshop
there giving a tour of the field team
six field team six I believe is the the
texting campaign so we did one on Mom's
demand actions website oh my God there's
so much resources on Mom's demand action
on gun safety and gun reform if you want
to go to that
uh if again if you want to go to the
playlist and watch that video on Mom's
demand action website you just go to
Round Table of democracy playlist here
on the Tony michaels.com or you can just
go to the YouTube channel and click the
playlist just click the playlist button
it'll take you to the playlist and you
can go to the round table of democracy
playlist there and you can check out
that video on Mom's demand action but
here is the tonymichaels.com if you want
to do a venmo super chat get in the
venmo Super Chat I will I will I will
tell uh MJ she's in here she says uh my
sanity fire emoji
MJ giving her her venmo Super Chat here
of my sanity fire Emoji I'm guessing I'm
guessing she means her cathartic release
uh
on the show on the show so thank you MJ
for the for the venmo chat Ben Mo chat
and you know what again if you guys get
too many of them I can't get to all of
them on the show I'll make some social
media videos or something respond to
your to your venmo super chat so get in
the venmo Super Chat and and do that
again the link is down below in the
description or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and you just click on venmo
Super Chat there you guys should use
that resource the Tony michaels.com
that's everything if you want to follow
me on all the social media channels and
I I know I say them all the time every
day you know I'm always saying
Facebook this this one this but if you
want just go to the attorney
michaels.com you can follow us anywhere
over there don't go anywhere I
appreciate all the Shameless plugs I had
to make there we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
looks like there's breaking news
possibly
[Music]
all right we're gonna go through this
here uh breaking news attorney general
get Merrick Garland of points Delaware
U.S attorney David Weiss a special
counsel and Weiss's investigation of
Hunter Biden
all right so basically he's making these
the United States Attorney that's
already over the case of under Biden a
special counsel in in Hunter Biden
now some may be pissed at this but
honestly at first glance I'm gonna we're
gonna watch uh the announcement here
it's only a minute and a half I gotta I
got the um the clip here for ABC news
but here's the thing what what actually
Merrick Garland is doing at first glance
again I I don't know the parameters I
haven't listened to garlic Garland's
statement here but it would appear that
he's he's ripping away the possibility
of the Republicans of making any kind of
bones about an investigation in the
President Biden
and Hunter Biden and the distinctions
between them okay so in other words
Merrick Garland is saying hey oh you
want it to be free and fair fine go
ahead investigate him in Congress keeps
talking about your lies keep lying out
in public but what I'm gonna do is
appoint a special counsel the guy who
already knows everything about the honor
Biden Gates give him more power to reach
in to if there's any tentacles to Joe
Biden and there won't be because there's
no evidence there's been no evidence we
know this
we know this
we know for sure that we have not seen
nor do the Republicans have any
any
of the ridiculousness
of the of the
non-evidence that they have produced for
us as the American people that somehow
Joe Biden has acted in a way
that he shouldn't be
again
a lot of people are going to misconstrue
this possibly but I believe that this is
Merrick Garland taking the politics away
from the Republicans is what he's doing
here he's definitely making sure that
they know that it's the person who knows
most
um here is the clip let me see if I can
play from the press conference here's
the ABC News special report let's see if
Merrick Lauren says anything in February
2021 U.S attorney Weiss was asked to
remain as U.S attorney for the District
of Delaware and in that capacity to
continue to lead the investigation
as I said before Mr Weiss would be
permitted to continue his investigation
take any investigative steps he wanted
and make the decision whether to
prosecute in any District
Mr Weiss has told Congress that he has
been granted ultimate authority over
this matter including the responsibility
for deciding where when and whether to
file charges and for making decisions
necessary to preserve the Integrity of
any prosecution consistent with federal
law the principles of federal
prosecution and departmental policies
in a July 2023 letter to Congress Mr
Weiss said that he had not to that point
requested special counsel designation
on Tuesday of this week Mr Weiss advised
me that in his judgment his
investigation had reached a stage at
which he could should continue his work
as a special counsel and he asked to be
so appointed
upon considering his request as well as
the extraordinary circumstances relating
to this matter I have concluded that it
is in the public interest to appoint him
as special counsel
this appointment confirms my commitment
to provide Mr Weiss all the resources he
requests
there you go there you go so make
politics out of that
make politics out of that Republicans
what are they going to say ah Merrick
Garland made sure to give more prosecute
power against Hunter and Joe Biden and
we don't like that because Weiss was
appointed by Trump and he remained in on
this case they didn't change the
prosecutor because obviously the
president's son was being investigated
by Weiss in his office in Delaware
again
folks I I know it I know sometimes
sometimes it seems like they're winning
but they are losing this battle they are
losing
and now what what are they going to say
what are they going to say because
here's the thing they always remember
remember when there was a special
counselor what was his name his name was
Bob Bob Bob Miller I don't know Mueller
Bob Mueller remember when they said
a special counsel cannot indict a
sitting president you remember that
do you remember
do you remember oh yeah see and the
other thing is too that the Republicans
can't decide what an impeachment inquiry
is what an impeachment inquiry means and
how far impeachment inquiry can go
listen Joe Biden based on the evidence
that Republicans don't have because they
don't have any evidence to impeach Joe
Biden
but the non-evidence that they have is
only going to result in a floor vote for
impeachment of striking it down the
Republicans cannot bring impeachment to
the floor of the house without an
affirmative vote it will destroy them it
will destroy their integrity with the
Maga cult if they still have any
and that is why they have not moved to
an impeachment inquiry yet it is why
they will not move the reason why is
because Republicans are [__] Liars
they're [__] Liars what could
possibly be the defense
of Joe Biden when there's no evidence
against him a defense of what
what is the defense of impeachment
to what evidence do I have to defend
myself that they don't like me
that they don't like the business deals
that my son did
it's ridiculous it's absolutely 100
percent
ridiculous but this is the Maga cult
this is the Republican house
they're supposed to be ridiculous at
this point
I mean we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life what would it
be if the heels in this story
we're not [__] boxes
this would not be a great story if the
heels in this battle in this wrestling
match as they want to have it be they
want it to be reality TV oh they want
this [__] to be reality TV that's what
this that's what the hunter Biden [__]
committees are about when they clamor on
and show photos of Hunter Biden screwing
prostitutes and [__]
that's what it's all about
is to say hunter Biden 100 by 100 by 100
Biden Hunter Biden 100 Biden 100 Biden
Hunter Biden
foreign
now now we have Weiss as a special
counsel because he requested it Merrick
Garland granted his request
making the Department of Justice and
Merrick Garland appearing less political
less political not more political less
political this is going
to make the American public believe that
yeah I mean what are you going to do
now he's a special counsel looking
because now like he can charge in any
jurisdiction that he wants he can
investigating any jurisdiction that he
wants
he has brought subpoena power now he is
basically separate from the Department
of Justice
to investigate the president's son
who was almost damn near pled guilty in
court
to three charges
after after he paid the taxes that he
was charged with
now who knows maybe David Weiss has
found more crime for more individuals
that are related to Hunter Biden and
that's why he needs to move to be a
special counsel
David Weiss appears to be to all degrees
of being a trump appointee
other than to be assigned to prosecute
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden
but David Wise has to operate in the
bounds of the law too
so we'll we'll see
I tell you what for the Republicans you
can guarantee you that this special
counsel of David Weiss
is gonna go over like a wet fart in a
white thong for them
I believe that Merrick Garland and
justice department and David White David
Weiss as a special counsel has now just
absolutely handicapped the House
Republicans and their lies
it's what it is
it's always
fake stupid [__] from them
from the house
and we'll see it more and more now that
there's an actual special counsel
assigned to the hunter Biden case
so good luck to them and their narrative
I'm going to go to the uh
uh some of these quotes that were given
uh this one specifically well let me see
if I can get this here
we go
um here we go here's uh chetkin this is
again
this is exactly what I've been saying
about checking and she sheep she said it
way out loud this morning in court this
is the transcript and quote why I intend
to assure that Mr Trump has afforded all
the rights that any citizen would have I
also take seriously my obligation to
prevent is called a carnival atmosphere
of unchecked publicity and trial by
media do you want Medias broadcasting is
Media
cameras and courtrooms broadcasting on
TV that's media
Carnival atmosphere she's not gonna let
her courtroom turn into a carnival
atmosphere and she says quote unquote
this case is no exception
no exception will she make
for this case I'm telling you there is
no more perfect judge
in this case in this moment in history
then chetkin she has not not only does
she absolutely have the wit
um to outsmart
the prosecution and
the defense both together because this
morning the prosecution Jack Smith
special counsel was actually asking for
a protective order of all evidence all
of it
and chetkin did not grant them a
protection order of all evidence only
that marked sensitive
and basically anything that isn't public
or quote unquote sensitive will not be
under this protective order Trump will
be able to to speak of evidence that is
at is out in public and there's a lot of
evidence out in public the January 6
select committee put out a lot of
evidence in this case so he will be able
to speak on that case and she is going
to ensure that he is going to campaign
she is not going to get in his way of
campaigning it is clear this morning
that she will not get in his way to
campaign but
when his campaign crosses the line into
witness tampering
in into into jury tainting
then she will step in
she made clear
and she gave Trump an opportunity
you know to behave kind of like you know
it's kind of like giving Dennis the
Menace you remember that show you
remember that cartoon
Dennis the Menace you remember that
she's kind of like giving Dennis the
Menace the the ability to
kind of do what he wants as long as he
plays by the rules she says in addition
the more a party makes inflammatory
statements about this case which could
taint the jury pool the greater the
urgency will be that we proceed to trial
quickly
I will take whatever measures are
necessary to safeguard the Integrity of
these proceedings very important coming
from jetkin there
making sure that Donald Trump
understands hey hey Grandpa if you if
you really want to make sure this trial
gets extended out as far as you possibly
can you might want to shut your [__]
mouth gag it fatty as I said in the
show's open I almost put that on the
thumbnail gaggit fatty we but shut your
mouth
I don't know some you know what if some
people say I'm body shaming but what do
you want from me he called Christy a fat
pig
You're Gonna Play in politics if you're
gonna make stuff political you're gonna
have to fight back
you shouldn't have to abide by certain
rules if they don't have to that's all
I'm gonna say
well let's see
um here we go here's another statement
that Chuck can emphasizes in open court
this morning check and emphasizes Trump
is subject to pre-trial release
conditions which include bar on
harassing or intimidating Witnesses this
is the witness part
uh specifically going after Pence I
believe and the reason why is because
technically Pence is a presidential
candidate right so Trump has the right
to talk about a presidential candidate
but he can't harass and intimidate him
based on this case or based on the
evidence and discovery that he finds or
does lawyers find the quote is all his
behavior and statements are governed by
conditions of release
so in other words I don't give a [__]
what you say about your freedom of
speech I don't care what you say about
the Constitution he's indicted under
that Constitution we have the
constitutional right to indict him on
these crimes and he's governed by the
conditions of his release that he agreed
to
got it period
so uh judge checking kicking him in the
balls even more
even more uh let me see if I can read
you uh here here we go
um Wyndham Windham the prosecutor was
making the argument this morning about
uh all materials basically all materials
and Discovery would be under the
protective order and checking was not
having any of that either judkin Kyle
Chaney reporting here checking is not
buying windham's argument to subject
quote non-sensitive documents in the
protective order
most of the Wyndham's arguments she says
are broad but don't make clear why the
material needs needs special protection
in other words anything marked
non-sensitive
will not go under protection
of this order it will be not part of
chutkin's protective order it's only
that of Mark sensitive and most of that
is going to be
most of that is going to be
uh in uh in the form of anything that
isn't public anything that's out in the
public maybe with the January 6th select
committee will be we got a lot of new
viewers this morning uh live here I'm
sure it's because of the breaking news
and how we cover the breaking news here
on the Tony Michaels podcast I just want
to let you know that we're live every
single weekday every single weekday we
are live noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours this is a
place where you can go and get your
cathartic release you can see how media
is supposed to be done how commentary is
supposed to be done at this hour of the
day
you just go to YouTube and search the
Tony Michaels podcast And subscribe
there you can watch us live every single
day if you're on the YouTube channel hit
the Subscribe button right now we're
trying to get to 20 000. we're so close
to 17 but hell let's get to 20 today why
not let's get to 20 000. spread this
around give this link to your friend
while you're there
you know what I mean
so subscribe to YouTube it's [__]
free anyways doesn't cost you anything
to subscribe to the YouTube channel and
hit the like button or if you don't like
what I'm saying yeah you can hit the
dislike button too engage how you wish
here at the Tony Michaels podcast we we
love all the lovers and all the haters
people love to hate me and they love me
do you love me and you love to hate me
it's either way
it's not it's not
it's not you know and no one really
hates me hates me they just love to hate
me that's it uh let's see if I can find
some more um
in this case hey here we go here is
checking on Donald Trump's uh First
Amendment you know this is a case that
they've been trying to make uh this is
something they've been trying to say uh
chutkin says quote Mr Trump like every
American has the first right First
Amendment right to free speech but that
right is not absolute as judge judkin
points out to the facts defendant's free
speech is subject to the release
conditions imposed at arraignment he was
arraigned he agreed to those release
conditions he is now subject to that
speech and it must yield to the orderly
she goes on to say and it must yield to
the orderly administration of justice
in other words if you get out of line
if you conflate your free speech with
violating your release conditions and
the speech thereof we will have an
orderly administration of justice
oh I'm telling you what I'm excited this
morning after listening uh reading
uh check-in's orders here now
I know that a lot of people are like
this is why we need cameras in the
courtrooms why why do we need cameras in
the courtrooms we do not need we can we
can get the transcripts it's easy to
know what the judge is saying with the
transcripts it truly is did we just pass
17 000 I think someone's saying we
passed 17 000.
I think we passed 17 000 that's reason
to celebrate thank you so much and
congratulations to the [__] em fam I
really want to thank you guys you guys
are the best the best audience in the
world really truly the the best audience
in the world is right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast no matter where you're
listening from and no matter where
you're chatting whether you're on
YouTube uh you're on our main Channel
you're on the upwire.com channel uh
whether you're over on Twitch and you
should follow us on Twitch it's free
just go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels maybe
you're watching on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook if you're not
watching uh if you're watching online
it's time to touch his channel on
Facebook come follow us too on Facebook
at the Tony Michaels and also if you're
listening and on the live chat on
Discord it's where the chat party never
stops it's 24 7. [__] family chat
over there
and I want to thank you for the 17 000
it I couldn't do it without you you're
the most important Cog in that wheel in
this show without you without you coming
here every single day and listening to
me yelling screaming to a microphone for
two full hours this would not be
something that we could do
and I appreciate every single last one
of you that is why I want to open up
patreon this weekend and give a free
membership so we can connect over there
as well uh everyone's uh jumping up and
down in the uh Discord chat they're
excited about 17 000 even on Discord
they're not even on the YouTube channel
right now they're over there chatting
over there and they're excited about it
that's the great part about the [__]
fam we're close knit
we've got it together we're in it
together
just like you know what happens here on
the show we have certain things that we
do and how we do them and it's Friday
it's Friday
did you know that it's August 11th
Friday and we're almost to the top of
the hour
and you know what it means on Friday all
the audience members tell them in the
chat what Friday means it means bone
head of the week that's right you vote
you decide for who is bonehead of the
week
and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez break
it down in the second hour every single
Friday of the bone of the week we have
great contestants here on bonehead of
the week and how here's how you vote if
you're a new audience member here's how
you vote on bonehead of the week on
Thursday night you go to the YouTube
Channel's Community tab so go to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube You'll
see the poll there on the community tab
you also see it on excuse me that's the
wrong one on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod you'll find it on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can vote every single
week for bonehead of the week get your
vote in we're just practicing voting
that's all we're doing we're just
practicing
practice some voting here practice some
voting there and we get to mock them you
know what I mean we need to mock the
Republicans all at the same time
we didn't get a lot of time yesterday to
talk about some of these fools
um so we put them on bonehead of the
week so we could talk about them and I
tell you what one of the congressmen
that made it on bonehead of the week
last night one of the
I didn't even I didn't watch the video I
just read the transcript
of what of what this congressman is
going to do he's going to file ah I'm
gonna file impeachment charges on this
present for bribery
oh okay oh it's kind of funny how it's
kind of funny how every time there's
something News about Donald Trump in a
court case it's kind and they're kind of
funny that the Republicans come up with
something new in the House of
Representatives like filing eachment
charges or more Hunter Biden cockpits
isn't that kind of funny and it kind of
weird that's how it happens yeah that's
how it happens
the Republican Party
with the Republican uh party let's see
if I can get some more um
Clips here of news that's coming out of
uh Merrick Garland
you did do actually you know what I'm
gonna go check uh I'm gonna go check
true social at the break we're gonna go
to the break here really soon I'm gonna
check uh tree social and see
if I'm gonna go check and see if Grandpa
Poopypants has made any statements on
the orders that were given down by
judge chenkin this morning uh we'll see
exactly how Grandpa responds in real
time so don't go anywhere we're gonna
come up with bone end of the week here
really soon we're getting really close
to the second hour don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome
back to the show
Friday
oh the week
are you ready for bone end of the week
I'm ready for the bone end of the week
what do you say
we're getting it we're getting all the
assets loaded and I'm waiting for a
game's Edge kids to make his way into
the studio so that we can do bonehead of
the week
until then we'll talk about a few things
again I want I want to reiterate that we
have now and because a lot of people
were talking about our YouTube super jet
not being enabled YouTube hates me
they're not gonna let me monetize based
on what I say
so you know what we came up with venmo
chat here it is venmo chat you send a
message to me in venmo I'll uh bring it
up on the show here and if I get too
many of them then I'll do some like some
videos or something you know I mean like
some Social Media stuff uh so you guys
can see your your comments and messages
that you send me there on venmo so the
the venmo chat
is the link is in is in the chat now so
go
go God get your uh venmo chant if you
want if you like the Super Chat thing if
you don't like the super chat then just
keep talking
just keep talking if you want it
I don't know people like the super chat
sometimes we'll see how we'll see how
the venmo chat goes if it doesn't go
well then we'll change it
if it goes well then we'll keep it and
and also don't forget to go where the
chat party never ends on Discord
um also the link is in the description
below here I'll put the link to the
Discord as well uh on the chat and where
you can have it here that way you can
have that here too
so we'll have the Discord there's the
Discord link there in the chat no matter
where you're at no matter where you're
at the Link's in the chat let's see can
we get the uh
I'm trying to find there we go I'm
uploading the assets as we speak that's
right I do the show and run the show
here
it's a little more difficult than some
people think
a little not much but a little
okay so let's talk about this chetkin
ruling this morning a little bit more
um again I I pop I I
had the mindset that judge chutkin would
not go outside the rules and abounds of
the law but she would be fair not only
fair to Donald Trump and his defense but
fair to the prosecution in their case
now she's done that this morning she
basically told Donald Trump hey look
stupid keep your [__] mouth shut
and I'll let you have the typical delays
in a federal trial
which are generally a lot of delays
because it is a very clunky system in
the federal system and the judges give a
lot of leeway to defense
they do they just do I don't know what
to tell you style works just how it
works
that's the system you can be mad at me
all you want for telling you the truth
but don't be mad about the truth
okay you can be mad at me for giving you
and delivering you what is real
and not a bunch of misinformation and a
bunch of [__] to make you feel good
about what's gonna what's gonna happen
on what's not gonna happen to be frank
and a lot of people are gonna be upset I
think in the coming months with
checking's ruins
I think they're going to be really upset
on the left not on the right on the left
because she's she has proved this
morning that she is going to give a fair
shake to the defense and the prosecution
she has given every reason for Donald
Trump to shut his mouth and for him to
get the delays that he so wishes in this
trial
she also gave the prosecution the right
to have a protective over order over
over sensitive information but not
sensitive as they asked you don't get to
protect every single piece of evidence
just the stuff that is quote sensitive
so judge chatkin and operating in a
courtroom the way that a judge should
I hate to tell you and I know you don't
want to hear this but this is what
Justice should look like
it should come from journalists being in
the courtroom
transcribing those words from the judge
from the prosecution from the defense so
us As Americans yet get to hear what
happened as transparency but it's not a
reality show it's Justice
it's not a reality TV show folks our
democracy should not be a [__]
reality TV show as much as we want it to
be
oh my god do you have any idea do you
have any idea the ratings that cable
news and our show my show do you have
any idea how how many views I would get
if I had video of Donald Trump in that
Federal courtroom yes oh man
but there is more important things at
stake there are way more important
things at stake than me getting a clip
and showing you a clip and cheering and
mocking him it is more important to
receive Justice on this case
specifically
this case specifically
it is more important that justice has
done than any other measure
and again we're going to politicize the
[__] out of everything that we can in
the election realm in that Battleground
for the ballot that's what we should do
we should understand that the election
is separate from this criminal case just
as Donald Trump and his defense team
should understand
that that elections and this criminal
case are two different things
someone's pointing out Peter here in the
chat is pointing out yes Georgia can
Georgia can the laws in Georgia allow
Georgia to have cameras in the courtroom
that is what the Georgia laws allow so
if you're really wanting cameras in the
courtroom that that's where you should
put your focus not and and judge chutkin
I believe through cold water
more cold water than I ever could
and I know a lot of people don't like
that I said that for the LA and they
were like why do you keep going on and
on and on about this because this
morning
I don't I don't [__] say [__] here on
this show to make you feel good
I tell you what the [__] I think is
gonna happen
regardless
of how it's going to make you feel now I
do it in a way that's cathartic you know
that that's peppered with
profanity poetry
as I like to call it
but that is the intention is not to
mislead you because it makes you feel
good or it gets you riled up
that's not the intention
the intention is to deliver you what
what is closest to the facts that I can
deliver you in the National mood and
narrative
it's what I do
don't hurt anybody's feelings don't eat
look I can't help it if I hurt your
feelings no matter what I say no matter
what I say people aren't gonna like what
I say
that's just how it works in this game I
don't know if you know that that's
that's that's the really that's the
thing that the left really doesn't
understand
they don't and the media doesn't
understand it either oh my God the media
is so horrible there's like oh we don't
want to appear biased bias bias to what
the truth get the [__] out of here there
is no bias to the truth
if if you're if you're feeding viewers
for misinformation that you know is
[__] you're feeding the
misinformation no matter what side or
what narrative you're doing it from you
do not have to do that
it is a thing you don't have to do I
prove it every [__] day two hours a
day yeah we joke and we have fun here
and we mock
and we we find all kinds of hilarious
connections to coincidence yes we do
that
But ultimately I'm not here to feed you
and pack your mind full of a bunch of
[__] rigged poles a bunch of [__]
data and a bunch of narrative that no
one needs or wants
it's supposed to be real and raw it says
it in the um in the intro says that in
the intro so I know you're joking I know
you're joking Idol
I know you're being sarcastic don't hurt
feelings but you know what I that's I
can't that's not my job is to not hurt
feelings
so [__] them actually it is my job to
hurt feelings isn't it
oh boy oh boy oh boy okay so um uh Gabe
Sanchez needs just a little a little bit
longer so let's see if I can um
if I can get the uh bonehead of the week
going here it looks like and we're going
to bring Gabe Sanchez in here just in a
minute let's see are we are we there
yeah okay I looked on true social on the
break
and grandpa has not made any definitive
statements yet he actually hasn't have
any activity on uh on his uh truth fraud
Social account uh in about an hour he's
been like reposting [__] over there
um here's here's a video though and this
is uh
one of the reasons why I say Mike Pence
it's not going to be uh as much that
he's going to be able Trump that is
is going to be an intimidate him as a
witness much longer we know Mike Pence
is one of the only Witnesses quote
unquote that is actually campaigning for
president United States which puts Mike
Pence in a difficult situation it also
puts Donald Trump balls in the ringer
because he can't say things that would
intimidate Mike Pence as a witness but
he has to campaign against him which
does he really does Trump have to
honestly Mike Pence is like below one
percent isn't he I know it's even
qualified to be on the debate stage yet
I don't even know this
I don't even I don't even know is he
qualified to be
on the [__] stage to debate
so if you can't even get on the stage to
debate are you really running for
president of the United States is are
you I mean or or is it just all [__]
but here is a here is a a video from the
Iowa State Fair
uh where everyone all the Republicans go
to eat corn dogs and drink lemonade and
try to see if they can
fake kiss babies you know what they'd be
like oh I love babies they don't like
babies
it's all [__] but they go to the
Iowa State Fair and here's some Trump
supporters let's see if the Trump
supporters
welcomed him with open arms at the Iowa
let's see
Traders
he is not a Christian when you say
higher power
oh so no they are not welcome welcoming
bins with open arms uh all but saying
hang my pants I wonder if she was one of
the ones that January 6th hang my pinch
hang Mike Pence Mike Pence isn't a
Christian she says
oh my God that is hilarious you know
what's the best part about this is Trump
supporters this same this same Trump
supporter probably back in 2016 was was
oh I bet they were super excited I met a
lot of these people and you probably did
too think all the way back to 2016 right
she being rewind your mind
back to when
Donald Trump picked Mike Pence I had a
lot of people tell me
like to my face I'm like you're really
not gonna vote for this fool are you and
they're like well I'm not really voting
for Trump
Pence is a good Christian I'm voting for
him because I think Donald Trump won't
last but a couple months and then Pence
will be president and we'll have a real
Christian as a prayer like that was
their [__] right and now they're
like Mike Pence isn't a Christian
because he didn't make Donald Trump the
dictator whatever the [__] it is well
let's continue though it's great it's
great this is a great video we don't
mind
[Laughter]
why are you here today
and everyone at the at the saver is like
hey Lady this is a this is a state fair
this is what are you doing this isn't a
this isn't January 6th
oh my God nothing could please me more
than Trump supporter Listen to listen
Trump supporters are showing up at other
Republicans [__] and doing this do you
have any idea
how how great this is for the general
election do you have any idea how great
this is this is fantastic for the
general election especially in places
like Iowa to State Fair where people are
going to have images of trump supporters
acting like [__] buffoons
absolute buffoons at the at the Iowa
State Fair
um
roydenblade says shut up Karen I mean
yeah you know you want to call her a
Karen but I honestly I want her to go
protest all the Republican candidates I
hope she does this for the santis I hope
she continues to do it for Pence
um Tim Scott everyone but Trump I want
her to do this for
I I think I think I don't know if she
has an organization that we could donate
to where she goes and just yells and
screams for the cameras
listen this this is the politicization
that I'm talking about right this is the
wedges that we draw if we divide up the
Republican party here we will win in
2024 and not just the top of the ticket
folks
if we divide up their vote they may
self-suppress their themselves
right they may self-suppress their vote
Republicans not Maca Republicans people
who go vote
reliably for Republicans may not go vote
because they're so discouraged about how
not just Trump but his supporters are
acting
so let them step on these rakes
let them step on these rakes
do it
show who you really truly are
and someone says she's a trump Karen
yeah yeah she is uh pH here on YouTube
says she's a TR she's a trump Karen uh
she's like take a picture of my shirt
[__]
oh my God they're so fun to watch aren't
they it is like a goddamn reality show
and you just can't look away from these
people
dark Pepsi says up ma'am this is a
Wendy's
oh man
oh boy it's it's gonna it folks I'm
telling you we're not gonna need yeah
we're gonna have plenty of footage
from this campaign in this election and
we'll have plenty of it I'm gonna show
you the uh uh these requests from Jack
Smith here and his special counsel
they're requesting a January 2nd a trial
date now having seen what judge checking
said this morning I really highly doubt
that this January second thing happens
now honestly it's probably not going to
happen based on what she said this
morning when she said hey man I'm Gonna
Let You delay
if you shut your mouth so but this is
the the order
um
the minute order from uh
the this United States of America and
the special counsel Jack Smith that they
want the trial date set on January 2nd
of next year it is clear that Jack Smith
and his team are trying to move as fast
as they can on Trump uh to get this
trial over with before they get into the
primaries it is likely not to happen
though
this is just just weeks before the Iowa
caucus where which where we saw Pence
now in Iowa and we'll see more images of
these morons at the Iowa State Fair
so just hang tight on this I think I
think Chuck can she hasn't made a ruling
already I don't think she was planning
on making an opening court that that's
the way it appeared this morning
um as she was being quoted by
journalists online that inside the
courtroom that she was going to make
this this decision then uh we'll we'll
see if we'll see if she makes that
decision
I'm not sure if that has been made let
me see if I can find an update here
if we have now again this morning big
news though is that that David Weiss has
been upgraded
he's been upgraded to special counsel so
that that's trending like crazy
um uh chetkin let's see if she's
actually given uh
um I don't know if she has actually sent
a trial it doesn't look like she's set a
trial date yet it'll probably come some
time today but the news is is that if
you're if you're just watching the news
is that chutkin has ruled in the
protective order matter that Donald
Trump shall not shall not intimidate
Witnesses is not his free speech to
intimidate Witnesses it will break his
pre-trial conditions he cannot use that
speech as the well the defense of free
speech for that speech and also uh
chetkin has ruled in the protective
order manner that will only protect
sensitive information in Discovery
um so only sensitive information will be
quote gagged and there's not actually a
gag order that was given to Trump this
morning there was no official gag order
that I can see
yet yet being the key word
we should use that yet
because it's likely and I checked too
social hell let's check it again let's
see if we can check true social and find
out if grandpa has already been losing
his mind he's been retweeting a lot of
stuff this morning about the santis and
you know fake ass rig polls that he
likes
um
what the hell is that about again he's
going after biting into santus on his
fraud Social account
but that's that's pretty much about it
uh we should have the Gabe Sanchez here
pretty quickly I've got the bonehead of
the week all cued up
so I'm gonna message him here
so tell him I'm ready when he is so we
can do this because uh again after
Today's show about about an hour after a
show I think we in the show about an
hour after that
um we will do a Roundtable democracy on
field team six if you're not aware of
what Roundtable democracy is it's a
thing we do over on patreon but I post
it publicly you guys you guys can see
this publicly it's not anything we hide
once we do the round tables we do the
workshops WE Post those videos public
for you to watch and for you to to enjoy
and engage I always tell you on this
show to engage in your democracy
and I never really gave the tools so
what we're trying to do with the [__]
fam together we're all trying to do it
together we're trying to just find these
resources that you can use to engage in
your democracy we don't have to reinvent
the wheel we can just go find the wheel
and use it if that makes sense let's
just pull the wheel out of the closet
we've already given a couple workshops
on on different resources one of them is
fivecalls.org that was a really good
website tour uh our our local librarian
the mighty librarian has put together a
resource on a state-by-state election
laws and it's easy to find you just go
to the state that you want on the list
and click and it goes directly to their
election laws a really good resource for
anyone to use when they need to use it
that's all there on the playlist of
Roundtable democracy we also took a tour
of Mom's demand action website holy moly
you talk about the amount of resources
that are on that website you you could
spend months on that website and not get
all the resources that you need they're
all there they're all right there uh so
so go to
roundtableofdemocracy.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com you'll see the link
for the roundtables of democracy
playlist there are if you're on the
YouTube channel subscribe to the YouTube
channel you will find all those videos
that we do on patreon absolutely free
here on YouTube you just go to the
playlist Tab and you click Roundtable
democracy playlist and you will find
those videos that we do and this
afternoon about an hour after the show
we are going to do one on field team six
a lot of people been excited about this
Workshop they want to see how can I get
involved by texting
by texting and field team six has a
really great resource to do that and
we're gonna go we're gonna go over there
this afternoon to look at that how you
can engage in your democracy uh using
the field team 6 resource again these
are just resources that all exist here's
the funny thing
the Democratic Coalition has a lot of
different small little groups that do a
lot of different good things
but there's no one thing that connects
them all
right they're not all working they're
not working against each other just all
working independently to try to help
democracy and all I'm trying to do is
show you all the resources that you have
available to you to go use to engage
because that's always been the question
well what do I do Tony you say engage
but what do I do to engage how do I do
that
that's not for me to find out that's for
you and your talents to to decide maybe
you're good at making phone calls maybe
you're good at writing postcards maybe
you're good maybe you're good at door
knocking and talking to people in person
maybe you don't want to talk to people
in person maybe you definitely don't
want to make phone calls so maybe you'll
write letters maybe write some emails
maybe just maybe you'll get involved in
text campaigning
sometimes folks have a little extra
change laying around that you can give
to certain races that are going to make
a huge difference on the outcome of our
democracy
and we can all use that Focus we can all
use those workshops and these are going
to be very specific short workshops so
you're not going to have to watch like a
three hour video
that's not what this is about 10 15
minutes at the most is how long these
videos are
for you to to see a resource that you
can engage in your democracy she'll go
to Roundtable democracy.com or go to the
Tony michaels.com click the round table
a democracy playlist or if you're here
on YouTube subscribe right now you go to
the playlist Tab and you'll find the
Roundtable democracy all those videos
and all those workshops are there free
for you to view
so don't miss the Roundtable democracy
go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
we're gonna do one an hour after show on
field team six so if that's one you
wanted to attend
make sure you attend it or just go to
patreon.com to find the link or you'll
be able to watch it tomorrow tomorrow
you will be able to watch it we'll make
it public on the playlist and you'll be
able to watch it don't go anywhere when
we come back
it's Friday so we're gonna do bone of
the week right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
still waiting on um game Champions
there's some speculation over on the
Discord from Andy s Andy s says did
PornHub crash Gabe's internet
um now we are now we are at zero days
big staff over on Twitch can she's got
the camera going we're at zero days zero
zero days talking about porn because of
the Discord chat if you wanna if you
want to get on the Discord jet where the
chat party never stops it goes 24 7 over
there
um you can get over there and get in the
live show chat right now they're all
chatting away and yes skip points out
with a with a me mirror zero day since
last accident
[Laughter]
so they're listening and live over there
on on Discord so don't forget I also
have another venmo chat came in you can
send me a message on venmo the link is
down below in the description Andreas
says sore throat meds just in case I
think are you wanting me to buy like
sore throat spray because I have to yell
and scream so loud is that what you're
wanting Andrea so thank you Andrew for
the for the venmo chat see the venmo
chats are gonna be like
if we don't have suit we don't have
super Chats on YouTube and a lot of
people like the super Chats on YouTube
but they won't let me have them I don't
know what else to say they just don't
like me so they won't let me have them
so we're going to figure out a way
around this and we're gonna do venmo
chat so you can send me a message on
venmo and do a venmo chat you can use
the the little
the little
scan thing there or or you just go to
the Tony michaels.com
thetonymichaels.com the venmo chat
button is right there you can send a
venmo chat from there so thank you
Andrew and thank you MJ for the venmo
chants the venmo chants today
we're still waiting on Gabe saying I
don't know where he's at I have no clue
he's probably still building that stupid
bunker that George Soros was trying to
pay for how am I supposed to know how am
I supposed to know oh earlier the other
oh this is one thing I wanted to show
you let me show you this now let's go
back to um
uh the website here the Tony
michaels.com because I don't know if you
guys know this but but pardon blankets
are real did you know that that part of
Lincoln's are real now it's a real thing
I know it forever it's been some sort of
you know
fake commercial on here but it's real
now so you go to the Tony michaels.com
this is a perfect place to go here's the
venmo Super Chat the patreon
here's how you link your Amazon and
Twitch account here's the round table
democracy playlist but right here is
Gabe Sanchez's merch you see that
official [__] up merch Gabe Sanchez's
merch stores right here just click on
that let me see if I can bring a store
up here so here's his store let's see if
we can get this going here's the store
okay look there right there pardon
blanket
you can get a pardon blanket it's a real
thing right here on Gabe Sanchez's store
pardon blanket there's this pardon
blanket so go to store dot I am Gabe
sanchez.com that's
store.imgavesanchez.com or you can go to
thetonymichaels.com and you can find
Gabe Sanchez's
store right here so go support uh gay by
getting your own very pardon blanket
and protect yourself
or send it to one of your Trump
relatives you know what I mean maybe
it'll make maybe to make good Christmas
gifts for your Trump relatives that
they'll need a pardon blanket I don't
know maybe they'll end up like Craig
Robertson
my God this story
this Craig Robertson story
insanity
that he thought he was I don't know what
he thought to be Guan honest with you
but this is the delusional type stuff
that is going through the brains of
these boneheads
well I mean what do you want
it this is how it's going to happen this
is how it's gonna play out
uh let's see what else oh wait wait wait
we might have something from
um
we might have some oh someone just
pointing out that we have we we've
passed a thousand likes here on the uh
the show today so hit the like button
while you're here if you haven't already
they're trying to remind me to be better
at YouTube they really are and why not
you might as well subscribe to the
YouTube channel it's free it's free
um so this seems to be some reaction
here uh from a representative Smith I
believe it's representative Jason Smith
from from Missouri my home state of
Missouri he's not my representative but
it looks like
it looks like is this this is from
moments ago let's listen jumping on the
breaking news with us first what is your
reaction to it
it's it's great to be with you Sandra I
think that this should be concerning to
all Americans that this is a tent to
whitewash the Biden family corruption I
mean Mr Weiss is the single architect
that the judge in Delaware throughout
just a few weeks ago as saying it was
awful and unfair there were Provisions
okay if you're unclear about what
Merrick Garland did this morning is good
for our country if you're unclear about
it Jason Smith is is sending you the
biggest signals of all Republicans are
[__] pissed
they're pissed but David Weiss has been
named special counsel it handicaps their
entire narrative
handicaps it totally destroys their
entire narrative that somehow someway
someone's being protected now what
they're trying to do what they're going
to try to do is say David wise's deep
State and this is the Deep State making
the Deep State even deeper is what
they're going to do but their bitching
is is obvious it's obvious because their
arguments and their evidence doesn't
exist
it does not exist and they cannot go
into a courtroom with the evidence that
doesn't exist
or an impeachment that is why they keep
talking about an impeachment inquiry and
never actually doing it because they
know what it means you cannot they
listen and I want them I want them to do
an impeachment inquiry folks this is I
want them to do it
the Republicans in the house should
throw that rake out there and [__]
Jump On It
but the reason why the Republicans have
not moved to an impeachment inquiry is
because an impeachment inquiry has to
result for them in an impeachment of Joe
Biden on the floor of the house
anything less their base in the Trump
Maga cult will eat them alive
do you understand
because they clamor for things that
can't happen that's why I urge you not
to clamor for things that cannot happen
it's ridiculous makes no sense to stake
your political game on something that
isn't going to work
now their entire political personality
is to prosecute Hunter Biden and somehow
make Joe Biden impeach because Hunter
Biden exists
it's ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous
but it's what their personnel political
personality is in this moment because
they're a bunch of buffoons
and we should give them just enough rope
to hang themselves because here's the
thing if they do an impeachment acquirer
it has to move to impeachment if it
moves to impeachment it has to pass on
the floor
their political existence relies on it
so why not just tease impeachment
inquiry for the next six months
why not
why not well now do your impeachment
inquiry now that there is a special
counsel investigate the investigators
you [__] do it
do it I Dare You James Comer and Jim
Jordan investigate David Weiss and the
special counsel call them to Congress do
it
do it
do it today and keep doing it step on
those rakes please
please and thank you let's go back to uh
Jason Smith Jason Smith there's a [__]
box by the way I mean he is a republican
so it's kind of obvious but Jason Smith
is one of these ones he's absolutely
obsessed obsessed with Hunter's hog he
can't get Hunter's hog out of his mind
but let's let's keep listening Legends
within that that sweetheart plea deal
that granted complete immunity to Hunter
Biden for these crimes and future crimes
and she even stated that she's never
seen anything like that before and who
was the architect of that now the person
who Garland who President Biden's
justice department just appointed
himself
Congress is investigated uh Jason Smith
is more of an idiot that I relied on
than possible Gabe Sanchez here's what
Jason Smith is saying is he's saying
that David Weiss is is Joe Biden's lap
dog well they're always going to say
that they're always anyone who's
appointed by Merrick Garland is you know
transitive property is appointed by Joe
Biden and then under this Administration
is going to be unfair to them that's
what it is but this morning Merrick
Garland didn't appoint David Weiss's
special counsel he made clear in the
press conference he said I I awarded
David Weiss special counsel because
David Weiss asked for it no no Tony
you're not listening to what he said
you got to remember that whatever you
think the person said is the complete
opposite of what they actually said so
when somebody say it so you know lyrics
it is Mary Garland could go to the
podium and say I only have one statement
to say and it is this guy is blue and
then Mac will be like no no
water is wet no way that can't be
possible no matter what is said under
this Administration and under this doj
even though at every point when someone
goes well uh Mike Pence should get a
special counsel okay Joe Biden should
get a special counsel okay Hunter Biden
should get a special counselor okay man
like how well [__] it well well everyone
gets it's [__] Oprah you get a
special counsel you get a special
counselor you get a special counsel
right and no matter how many people get
appointed special counsel to different
investigations they will not be happy
because they believe that it's unfair
Justice it's a Witch Hunt it's all a
political persecution against Trump
all Trump has to do is shut the [__] up
and nothing would ever be this issue
right if he could hold if he could if he
could hold on to his own just you know
self-restraint just hold on to his
feelings and the things he wants to say
and not onto documents we don't want him
to hold on to documents hold on to his
feelings and keep them to himself maybe
go see a therapist talk to someone
because we know that he doesn't he's not
good with his emotions he likes he gets
so frustrated he yells he spurts he
complains he he whines like a little
[__] that's what he is
but if he if Donald Trump could just act
like an adult which I know is is very
impossible if well I'm not going to say
it's impossible it's very improbable
[__] it it's impossible Donald Trump
cannot act like an adult he listen he
has the right to remain silent but not
the ability right he just doesn't yeah I
mean you gotta remember it's like he's
gonna throw a fit someone says hey we're
gonna look into this don't say anything
he goes oh I'm gonna say everything and
today judge chutkin was like [__] sit
down
well you know she gave him really good
incentive too I I have to say yeah
is not only fair but she's really smart
here because she knows that you know the
boundaries that she has to stay within
and I I believe she's going to stay in
those rules and boundaries of the law
and the one thing that she did is she
looked at Trump's attorneys and and she
knew this message would really resonate
with him she's like look chucklehead you
get to do I know you want to delay the
trial I understand why it is so
important for you to delay the trial I
get it and I'm willing to go along with
some of that
if you just keep your [__] trap shut
right so keep your mouth shut be good
don't say a [__] don't intimidate
Witnesses don't try to taint the jury
pool and I'll play your stupid delay
game I believe that's me I I believe
uh I mean it goes It goes and uh you'll
you'll see it I'm making an update to
the to the what was that because I
covered before and I was like [__] this
happened I might as well throw this in
there and it it goes to show that Donald
Trump's lawyers like John lauro John
Laura was like yeah this guy's a [__]
idiot and then today I was like God damn
dude he's brilliant are so dumb this
because it was can you imagine hiring
that guy to defend you in a case as big
as January 6. I can't imagine and like I
I briefly mentioned in the what was that
that I've got coming out which everyone
should go uh check out my patreon if you
don't already uh but the the guy
uh John lauro if people are if you're a
basketball fan then you might know who
he is but there was a case back in 2007
with Tim Donahue which was the referee
who was taking bribes and pain right
yeah I watch I watched the net in the
Netflix uh yeah yeah he's so he's in
that Sports One or whatever it is yeah
so yeah the same people who do like the
I think that either last dance or the
same people who did 30 under 30 or
something like that right they did this
Netflix documentary and in there that's
Tim Donahue okay Tim Donahue was the
referee from the NBA who was put on
trial and it was sentenced to 15 months
and I think he ended up serving like 11.
yeah right right but John uh John lauro
or John lauro is uh is the is the
attorney who represented him back then
well you know who else is an attorney
who represented the the one one Michael
I have an Audi in that case too
maybe am I thinking right or is it no no
that's a different case that's a
different documentary
I'm getting them all confused I'm
getting all the the [__] Netflix
documentaries on cases I was thinking
about the court case um for the Lear jet
are not the leader jet but the the
fighter jet for Pepsi you remember oh I
don't know if I saw that one Michael
avenatti was the I mean I know who
avenatti is obviously like you know man
the guy he was on a rise like [__]
Icarus you're like right right and then
he [__] the bed
but yeah so that's there's actually
history back there and and the idea that
that John uh John lauro is
is uh representing Trump in this case is
it's [__] I think he's way out of his
League no okay way out of his League
what what gives you that idea I mean
come on come on I mean you know you know
who someone else's way out of his League
this guy look I want to do bone net of
the week yeah and this guy didn't make
it on there so I got to play this clip I
haven't watched this you see the clip
where he got the cell he got the phone
no grab grab that one grab that one I'll
I'll play that with DeSantis right yeah
yeah oh I'm always gonna I'm always
gonna leave her room to to [__] [__]
on DeSantis he got him phone it was too
[__] fun okay so here's here's the
Santa's night you see he's dropped the
sweater vest so I don't know if some the
new campaign managers like hey dude
sweater vest in Iowa in July and August
aren't that's not a thing like you
[__] idiot so they dropped the
sweater vest here he isn't just the
shorts he didn't he doesn't know how to
tuck in a shirt apparently
um but you know he is Ron DeSantis but
this is apparently this is a please clap
type of moment so let's well this
campaign is a please clap that is true
if you had to Define Rhonda santis is
just like right out of the gate from the
Glitch announcing his candidacy on
Twitter spaces
please
please Clap That would be his campaign
uh slogan and somehow and somehow I
would say it sounds more pathetic and
depressing than Jeb Bush he goes he's
like it's just like because he probably
goes please
that's probably what he does
please clap please clap and then he goes
the Android thing where he realizes he
shuts down he goes because his
campaign's like stop laughing it's it's
weird it's almost like the programming
of the Android like kind of the system
the the internals of of Ron the Android
DeSantis it says go manic right super
high shut down
[Music]
all right he definitely has needs
medication but let's listen here into
this clip and see what happens and our
state has never been better as a result
of our decision to keep Florida free
actually it hasn't
isn't there an outbreak of leprosy in
Florida right now but here's the deal
and our state has yeah and they're all
like
I love this I love this woman in the
back though
is she like looking around the corner
and she's like I wanna I wanna watch but
I don't want to be in the crowd right I
don't want to be seen on videos she's
trying to like also where is he having
that that little like stump speech it's
it's like a back alley of the side of
like a [__] bank and he's like back
there right I have no ideas they
probably wouldn't let him be out in in
the open so like yeah come back over
here yeah so that what what is this is
this an Iowa too yes in malaria then
malaria sorry okay it's not just leprosy
if anyone thought things like polio
leprosy and these other things that
science had you know pretty much
cut down to almost zero we did guess
what yes what Republicans know how to
bring that [__] back they know how to
make leprosy great again
oh well Rhonda Santos here what what is
this he's taking a phone call just just
watch this train wreck oh my God I can't
wait for different people have different
experiences but I think for with me one
thing you can know is okay well why is
he oh what's that I'm sorry that's my
phone I don't know why anyone's calling
me they know I'm here
um
turn it off [__] you know I think part
of the question you know when you look
at people like you know why are they
running okay and let's just be honest
there's some people that are not running
really to be president right they're
running for who knows why they're
running but but they're they're running
the only reason I'm running is I'm
running to win I'm running to serve and
I'm running to get the job done for you
but I think you could say why would you
want to do that all right
okay
I'm running for you and one guy in the
back's like yeah yeah and everyone else
is like we don't want you to run for us
we don't I just love the fact that look
man if you're if you're giving a speech
somewhere and you don't already have
your phone on silent or off as to avoid
distraction do not call attention to the
fact that you're getting the phone like
do you think it makes you sound more
popular like oh someone's trying to call
me
yeah and it's like sir we've got another
case of leprosy in Florida when you when
you're well when you were actually
seeing it's like uh maybe spam
this is Spam Builder it's just a [__]
random uh random call from someone
trying to sell you a vacuum or some [__]
Rhonda santis
um here's his here's his uh reaction to
um what the hell why isn't it damn it I
was trying I was trying to go on a joke
here and it and here's here's Rhonda
Santos's reaction to his uh here he is
here's his reaction to his flub there
it's you know it's kind of like he's
trying to be Jim Carrey as Ace Ventura
you know and then I think that's really
Ronda santis though I think that's
that's like that's why they get pissed
when he does it because it's the real
him and they're like yeah that's weird
that's weird as [__] stop doing that
yeah don't do that that's weird now
let's see here oh we got Lindsey
Graham's on Fox News his uh take on the
breaking news of uh David Weiss being
appointed special counsel let's listen
to Lady G see what he has to say the
United States senators and house members
so I think they're trying to shut down
the Congressional investigation to my
house colleagues you've done a wonderful
job I've tried to be helpful we're not
going to let this go Mr wise you're not
off the hook here this uh Friday
afternoon Gambit is not going to work
we're going to continue to ask questions
about the biggest sweetheart deal in the
history of America you know okay no no
no look nobody said that you can't
continue to investigate if there's a
special counsel happening and I just
want to point out if people don't
already know this
James Comer and the how in the house
Judiciary Committee the GOP LED house
Judiciary Committee that's coming after
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden have publicly
come out and said well we actually don't
need evidence per se to prove that Joe
Biden took money or that Hunter Biden
was involved in this because we know
there is no connection they have not
proven everything or anything that there
is no sign evidence proof document phone
call email whatever it might video
whatever it might be that shows that Joe
Biden worked with Hunter Biden to to
Peddle his influence and inherit and
earn money
and they have now moved the goal post
and said well okay I'm what's evidence
really like what's who needs evidence
like I'm not and I'm not kidding here
they have that's exactly what they're
saying they came out and they said we
don't actually need evidence to prove
this right which it is insane because if
you look at if you compare again you
know you could tell them that the the
sky is blue and they'll tell you it's
[__] orange but if you were to
compare what's happening with Donald
Trump and the fact that they're I just
want to point this out there's 11.6
million pages of Discovery in the first
batch alone from the doj that's going to
Laurel who by the way in the in today's
hearing was like well I don't think
we're I mean I'm gonna I need more time
to remove the documents because they're
not going to have it ready and then and
and uh
and the doj the attorney that was there
was like oh we're we're dude we're ready
it's all ready to go man we got 11
points we got roughly 11.6 million pages
that are ready to hand off to you right
now well and that's that's the other
thing and I I want I want I want to
point this out while you're giving
dropping that fact there that there's so
much Discovery in this
is that is that that is only an
indication and I think that's what
chutkin is telling Trump is that hey I
will allow your Council to go through
all this discovery every single bit of
it and it's a lot of it and it's a lot
of Discovery so he's gonna have to hire
a lot of attorneys to go through this I
don't see Laurel Laurel sitting there
all night long no I'm going again this
is the first batch right so so in that
in that in knowing that right and
knowing that the check-in is going to be
fair and letting the defense go through
that Discovery and knowing that it's
going to take a long time to get through
that Discovery and Donald Trump is going
to delay that process on purpose so he's
he's gonna not hire as many attorneys to
go through the discovery so that way it
takes a very long time to know the
discovery to create an offense for him
which there really is no defense
probably there's no defense
and the hearing again only proves
more so like it you know it bolsters the
idea lauro reads that's a good question
I honestly it you know I haven't seen
him read like on TV or on camera yet so
it's hard to say but what I will say
is that when you look at this whole
thing again you've got a guy who who
from what I understand is an effective
criminal attorney but does small quick
cases like his goal in in Florida has
been to get people in and out to get
businessmen in and out of court no
publicity at all that is the complete
opposite of this case uh so I mean yeah
but the fact the fact that they were
like yeah okay cool uh well we we won't
be ready like we we want to give it time
so that you guys can get all the stuff
in Discovery because we don't know how
much it is and he's like oh yeah I know
exactly how much it is it's 11.6 million
pages and they said like roughly a
quarter of that is documents that they
probably already have because it's like
pack related stuff which still means you
have over 11 million pages of documents
that are stuff that people haven't seen
right that are that I mean even they
reveal today that there's stuff from the
Jan 6 investigation that the public has
not seen video
um testimonial deposition the you know
documents transcripts uh receipts all
this stuff that they have that nobody
has seen in that 11 you know 0.6 million
pages of documents so it's going to be a
lot to go through and I and I love the
fact that John Laura was like uh God I
don't want
I don't want to have to babysit this guy
I don't want to have to sit next to him
as he slowly reads this [__]
Page by page because he's not going to
we know Trump he didn't never read the
briefs no well and minus DW here on
Facebook points out in other words get
started and that's basically what
checking was saying this morning she
said as much as that it's time to get
started it's time to move this along but
I you know she's not I I almost
guarantee and I think
um the decision for the trial date is
going to come sometime later on uh today
and when she's gonna set the first trial
date and remember it's going to be the
first trial that she's sending here it
will likely be delayed from the first
setting but she's probably not going to
even come close to January which I think
I think is it six
six or seven I forget which I I think
it's either six or seven cases that
Trump has in 2024 alone right right so
far yeah yeah just so far so so far so
far I'm sure there'll be more oh there
definitely will be more and there's
gonna be more bonehead of the week
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble Mega Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
hey Friday Friday it's gonna look like a
past few hour Friday we're almost
third hour now
we're gonna get through phone head of
the week
got a lot of blown heads gonna get you
maybe we'll do a little bit of Rapid
Fire
because as I mentioned earlier
we're gonna have a round table of
democracy on field Team Six
uh here in just a bit on the patreon
page go to patreon.com we'll do a round
table democracy this afternoon we're
going to tour the field team six uh
website Gabe give everyone a chance in
that Workshop to see what the hell is
that thing a lot of people have been
talking about field team six wanting me
to do a a tour of their website maybe
we'll get someone from field team six to
come and talk to us about their website
too I know Nick O'Neal the founder of
fivecalls.org is going to come talk to
us I think next month about
fivecalls.org in the round tables of
democracy we've already done a video on
that so go to the Tony michaels.com
you'll find the Roundtable democracy
playlist there but right now we've got
to do bonehead of the week who are our
contestants this week we have some great
boneheads oh yeah Clarence Thomas
unjustice Clarence Thomas and it's funny
because you actually spelled it wrong on
the on the yeah I'm not sure that it's
my fault or your fault I don't know I
mean look I got clearance Thomas on
there and I honestly in my tweet I said
uh made the mistake misspelled it said
clearance instead of clearance but it
actually makes a lot of sense because
you remember that he's on sale or for
sale he is for sale and he's on sale at
a discount at a discount for 38
billionaires right right it makes sense
it makes sense we also have another
person that's for sale Senator Joe
manchin uh we know he's we know he's at
Hawk with the um pharmaceutical industry
Joe manchin is and then representative
Greg stuby did we ever determine if
stewby's actually been on bone Ed before
no I looked I looked he's never been on
he's we've talked about him right for
that Zoom gun yeah well I think we I
think we brought up clips of Scooby
Dooby Doo yeah I mean that's that that's
what I think of when I think of uh right
we had another I forgot we called yeah
we did we did Scooby Dooby Doo and then
we did something else for him I forget
what we called him there was some other
nickname stupid ass I don't know stupid
ass stupid ass uh so stewby said uh
really and he [__] the bed yesterday
like the the wild part about Stewie
being on the bone of the week like right
now in this moment last night it made
sense but right now you're like well
that didn't [__] who gives a rat's
ass yeah really honestly it's just more
people I mean we could go through him
really quickly because it really is that
that's what I that's where I'm getting
at it let me see if I can even find why
he's on the bus was it Newsmax or was it
foxy was on um I think it was well
obviously it was on one of the ones that
it was like news he went on there was
like I'm gonna impeach Joe Biden right
yeah okay all right friend keep with
that yeah so it was really and the thing
about Scooby here of what he's gonna say
that he's going to impeach Joe Biden for
um
get this if you're gonna impeach a
president right think of presidents in
your mind okay all the presidents that
have ever existed get them in your mind
real quick okay bear with me here
and you're gonna you're gonna impeach
one for bribery extortion obstruction of
justice fraud
Financial involvement in drugs and
prostitution let me ask you which
president stands out to you the most
when you're when you're talking about
impeaching a president for those I mean
like if I had to run to that list it's
kind of like maybe the last one that was
right that's right the one the one who
literally has one of his uh one of his
trials next year is it's only fraud or
actually this year in October yeah yeah
well I you know who knows who knows
these are all gonna happen uh let me
tell you something I actually have never
watched this clip and I put him on the
bone of the week because I just read
what he said and I was laughing so
[__] hard when I read what he said I
didn't even need to hear Scooby-Doo
Scooby stupid ass say this
but it's it's beautiful this is going to
be a beautiful piece of content here I
tell you let's listen uh and tomorrow I
intend on filing impeachment resolution
on Joe Biden for bribery uh for
extortion obstruction of justice fraud
uh Financial involvement and drugs and
prostitution all of these things you
just touched on the highlights of some
of those yeah we have all the facts and
evidence now and individuals do you have
the vaccine that we did the
investigations that we got the
information before the American people
you have witness testimony you have
Financial records
you have text messages you have phone
conversations you have all of this
evidence now to corroborate and support
impeachment articles against the
president and I intend on filing those
tomorrow on all of these corruption and
bribery charges that uh you just hit the
top of the iceberg on
what an idiot okay
this is in this I just feel like it's
like if you had a counter I could
imagine I can imagine making this for
what was that honestly on its own it's
like Joe Biden crimes there's like the
list of all the crimes that he listed
right and then it'd be like which ones
that Joe Biden have and then everyone's
like a check mark would appear every
time for Donald Trump and he's already
indicted for yeah
what's funny what's funny about this is
now that I'm seeing this in the context
of the news today about David Weiss yeah
it almost feels like stoobie
Congress people knew that this was
coming
that David Weiss was going to be able to
was suggesting this because he suggested
this and apparently Department of
Justice reviewed it and then Merrick
Garland granted him his request to
become the special counsel as it reached
special counsel status this is like an
upgrade for a United States Attorney too
special counsel and it's almost like the
Republicans in the house seen this
coming so last night she was like you
know what I'll show them I'll file
articles of Patron on Joe Biden tomorrow
that'll show him yeah listen I told the
audience this before and stuby the
reason why he's a bonehead the reason
why this is really stupid is because if
they if this is really stupid
um is the reason why is because
if they go to an impeachment inquiry it
probably won't make it to the floor
which is going to be really bad for them
and even if it does make it through the
floor it is likely that it will not be
voted in the affirmative to impeach Joe
Biden which will be even worse for them
than going to an impeachment acquiry not
reaching they're never going to learn
man well they just
what they counted on what they counted
on was capitulation not just from their
base but also can you tell members of
Congress can you can you tell me is
David Wise a Democrat or is he a
Republican you know it since he was um
actually appointed by
um Donald Trump it probably would be
easy to say that he is um wants that one
party that kind of like Nazis they can't
they they kind you know what I'm you
know I mean they maybe they don't think
they're Nazis but the Nazis think
they're my Nazis what's that party's
name starts with an R is it Republicans
I think that's yes yes Republicans
it's crazy
[Laughter]
oh speaking speaking of uh parties uh
the reason why Joe manchin is on um
bonehead of the week is because he's
gonna switch parties he's not gonna be
he's not gonna be no no Democrat no more
okay
Bill Mansion saying he's not going to be
a Democrat anymore it reminds me of like
when you know when we're all kids and
we're like I'm running away from home
and then your parents are like okay go
ahead do it you won't get very far you
won't last very long I know you won't do
it you'll probably hide under your bed
and write a note and say you left and
then just wait for someone to look for
you and I feel like every time that you
and he probably will you know leave like
he's even been a part of the democratic
party this whole time but when I see
someone like Joe manchin say I'm going
to leave the Democratic party he's been
saying that [__] for a while and I was
like I'm gonna be an independent oh me
and me and Cinema we [__] over with
the Pharma companies or the oil
companies and this and that we're taking
the lobby it's like dude you've never
been part of the democratic party and
the fact that you continue to say you're
leaving and haven't left yet
it just takes away the effect the impact
of it all well the other thing too is
that this is Cinema and Mansion know
they're going to lose
um in their states if they don't do
something right so here's the politics
of this sentiment switched to
Independent because she knows she can't
win in the Democratic primary and the
reason why is because she basically [__]
all over the apparatus that got her
elected in the first place oh yeah boy
that was a smart move right so she
basically gave them the big [__] you the
people on the ground she got she got her
big Pharma lobbying money right and she
was like I'm good anymore it's sold out
[__]
I mean shit's expensive dude right you
know it's not I mean maybe because you
live in Arizona you think it's I mean
maybe it is cheaper obviously in Arizona
but like at the same time it's like dude
you
I imagine you've got many more years on
your life and things cost money and uh
and you're gonna You're Gonna Go the
fact that you [__] over these you [__]
over your constituents and the people
you run away from people hide in the
bathroom you have no intention of
actually helping people or support or
representing the constituents that you
were elected by
there's no way she I mean I believe that
she's going to get primaried and she's
gonna be done but well uh zephy here on
Discord the chat over there in Discord
is like fired up uh Mansion is straight
up manipulative loser and he also says
uh I'm in Arizona [__] Cinema which I
mean you know that's a good sentiment
and the whole Joe manchin thing but what
this is a set up to really honestly is
for Jill manchin to run on this No Label
stupid thing a lot of people think Joe
Joe manchin is going to step up uh to be
on this no labels ticket which again
folks I I know it's it's a danger to uh
our you know our nation that they that
they may take votes away from us but we
can't we can't get too focused on things
that don't matter like Joe Mansion I
don't know if you know this you call him
joke Mansion joke Mansion yeah joke
Mansion okay mansion that the reason why
having joke mansion on the top of the No
Labels ticket
will be good for us is because no one's
going to want to go vote for joke
Mansion also when you have it when you
if the is it really called No Labels
like that's the that's the yeah that's
the campaign they they want to have
that's the dumbest name I've ever heard
because when somebody sees that on a
ballot they're gonna be like what no
labels like what the [__] is this that's
like a like a fill in the blank like oh
we put something here as a placeholder
we meant to do it later but right now
they have no label like calling it no
labels I feel like is a a complete
branding mistake that you're making you
know it's just like it's like I don't
know if you saw a Jank recently it
sounds like he's trying to make like a
forward party 2.0 he's going on right
wing yeah he's going on right wing
talking shows he's [__] dude they're
[__] over the left man wait wait wait
wait wait wait back up back up because
people hate when I attack tyt so I
definitely want to do it in this moment
I'm gonna I'm gonna go let me find a
clip I saw him I saw him trending last
night yeah well I might call on Audible
I might call an audible for Elf our
dishonorable mention here we'll go to
our real dishonorable mention but I'll
get I'll give him leeway to have two of
them dishonorable mention 2.0 how does
that sound [__]
um
so Jake Unger tyt is he's he's doing
this it's both of them they're it's both
Jake and Anna that are dogs listen hey
hey
for knocking on tyt do you remember that
do you remember when you got my comments
you're like [__] you Tony I like tyt
they speak out against the left and blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
you remember that I told you
[__]
[__] I told you
I told you I think that I [__] got
their number all right I got everyone's
number here I don't have any reason not
to call you out you know this I don't
have any reason there's no reason
whatsoever I'm one of the most
independent people out there in this
space no one [__] really likes me how
Gabe you know this no one even knows
what to do with me literally people have
told us in meetings I wish you were
someone else yeah they did they're like
literally I you know I just you're you
but I wish you were someone else because
man you're crazy so listen when I say
these things I'm not saying them just to
[__] get clicks and ratings like they
are I'm telling you what I think and
let's see what what is this this is this
is a photo this is of someone that's
reviewing
um
yeah yeah I'm trying to find it but
basically in this this clip I saw last
night was was Jake was like oh you know
what we gotta do is we gotta uh he's
like we have division in this country
and we gotta work with Republicans and
basically he was like I'll work he's
like
it's very much this like I'm gonna go to
the center and I'm gonna work with these
people on the right and it's like I
don't know if the people on the right
really agree with the things that you
agree with
well and it feels like to me this is
more Marianne Williamson and this is
more tyt moving towards No Labels
movement and I don't know if you've done
anything looking at No Labels but one
the one organization has done a lot
against No Labels so far as the Lincoln
project you know your favorite game your
favorite uh content thiefs over there
when you project but anyways uh yeah
I'll knock them too I don't give a [__]
uh like a project Lincoln Project's done
a lot of work on rebutting No Labels but
that may be what uh tyt is setting
themselves up for is a big huge because
they know Marianne Williamson they've
been trying for many many months to get
people to know who she even is and they
still don't know is she still running
well I I assume so I don't know I
haven't the last time I heard her was on
Twitter when she said oh please Elon
interview me in spaces yeah when was
that when was that it was a few months
ago I feel like it was after it was
after no there's tyt is still talking
about Marriott Marion Williamson over
there every day and and that just shows
you how a relevant tyt is and I keep
telling you folks I keep telling you and
trying to give you an idea of what what
the future holds and tyt is not it
I know I know some that's a tough pill
to swallow but what tyt did is tyt drank
the [__] Kool-Aid of grift that's
what they draw and and they have
continued and continued to try to just
ride this grip train and that leads you
to a a [__] fast track to the right
yeah I don't know what what more to tell
you but yeah they're still pushing
Marion I'm trying to find
we're just gonna I don't know it's in
there but basically like we can watch a
little bit I haven't watched this video
I'm trying to find the clip that I saw
yesterday but funny enough these guys
also have a well they have a yellow
background there in stream yard right
now they are reviewing Jinx interview
that he had on the pbd uh podcast with
Patrick Bet David
um but I'm trying to find the clip I saw
yesterday anyway if anyone looks online
and they go onto Twitter and you want to
put in the Discord put in the live chat
there's a clip of him talking on this
podcast it is a Twitter embedded video
and I just can't find it so this is
these two guys now now what show is this
is this a right wing or a left wing oh
this is a this is the van this is the
Vanguard and it's oh okay yeah yeah yeah
I'm from a life perspective yeah okay
okay let's let's listen here yes guys
Jinx gonna make an attempt here to kind
of unite the left and the right behind
the policy of uh paid maternity leave I
want to tell you this Vanguard it looks
like they're copping us to be quite
honest I told you I was like
it's gonna feel weird I don't know I
don't know if uh I don't know if they've
if we got copyright on on the way our
show looks at this point but uh maybe we
should file for it we should keep doing
it so then every time we come back to
this clip they go to the clip we go to
the collection yeah and then she's like
Concepts well we should send this to
them so that they can [__] with it on
there okay well let's let's continue a
good very just cause and I appreciate
what Jake tries to do here unfortunately
what is exposed
um is that these right Wingers people
like Patrick are basically impossible to
work with on this front because all they
care about is the culture war and you're
about to see that Illustrated pretty
hilariously
I'm crazy but who could have seen that
coming right Republicans only caring
about the culture War what what it was
good very helpful did you have one other
you said you had one other thing yeah
one other thing is look guys I I'm
curious I'm genuinely super curious what
you guys think look I've kind of given
up on Congress I tried the inside
strategy I try to help Bernie uh I
formed Justice Democrats we've got 11
folks in Congress now but they just did
he just throw heat on Bernie I'm just
pointing that out you know I'm just
pointing at it seemed like he tried to
help it sounds like Bernie and the Bro
try to help him but those [__]
they they flipped on me he won't do it
they won't pass any laws that Americans
care about and by the way the culture
wars makes everybody rich and so the
right wing loves the culture wars the
left-wing loves the culture wars the
country hates the culture wars and the
country gets nothing because of the
culture wars yeah you [__] you
[__] you talk about a grifted
son of a [__] on the culture wars him
and Anna totally went [__] totally
turp and this is so [__] ridiculous
they they have all of a sudden flipped
anti-trans and they speak out against
trans women and all this get the [__]
out of here that that you're sick of the
culture wars get the [__] out of here
you stoked that fire every goddamn week
so uh what I want to do is ask
right-wing shows left-wing shows and
every show in the middle can we unite on
any post no because everybody says no I
will not Unite with Nazis
no hey Jank listen to me if you do here
if someone [__] send this to him Hey
Jake if you sat at a table with a
[__] Nazi you're a Nazi will you not
get it do you not get it he'd well I
don't know I don't know if he does get
it
oh that's all I need to see of it and
we're only a minute in that's all I
don't know but yeah basically there's
like I want to cooperate with neo-nazis
that's what I want to do there's that
clip on Twitter and and uh basically was
like I want to work with the right and
the left and uh I'll just I'll go to the
center and it's like oh so we're just
abandoning this Progressive side huh
right well again again hey hey all you
people out there who [__] didn't like
me talking [__] about tyt now say you
get in the comments tell me why I'm
wrong again okay do it do and keep
watching the show frankly or just be mad
at me and don't watch I don't give a
[__] whatever the hell you want to do if
you want to go watch Jake and his
[__] and this this [__] uh where
he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna welcome
Nazis with open arms because he wants to
be the center which is not the center
the center of the country right now is
not the center it's not there we do not
we have never in our country's history
had this extreme of a right wing in in
the Republican party we just have not
it's also I I do want to point out I
don't know if you saw this there was the
guy in Seattle that revealed the
identities of five different people from
Patriot front and Patriot front those
members are now suing that guy for you
know he's saying saying that they doxed
him because they lost their jobs and
this and that basically they [__]
around and they found out but what I
want to understand is these people that
are part of the proud boys right you
know the uh that are part of uh Patriot
front you know they're they're [__]
KKK whatever they might be all of these
people
they're very very proud they're proud to
be white right they're proud to go March
they're proud to go yell they're proud
it seems like a pattern I'm just saying
and they cover their face right they
work do they Hood their face
other ones hooded up from the bottom
right pulling up underwear on your face
right and everywhere they go right
they're like we're so proud we're
Patriots oh we're on the front lines
we're doing this America
and then as soon as they get exposed
right they're they're happy to do that
stuff in public when their face is
covered but as soon as their identity is
revealed
they get very upset they don't like they
they want to have it both ways they want
to be able to interact with people in
society
while also protecting themselves to show
up as a Nazi in public but cover their
face and as soon as they're unmasked and
revealed to the public to say hey look a
Nazi they go whoa no no no no no no no
I'm the victim I'm the victim and it's
like no no no you're a Nazi you're not
the victim you never were the victim
you're a Nazi you chose to play this
game you [__] around you found out and
I hope that more people reveal the
identities of all of these [__] Nazis
because if you decide that you're gonna
play with that you're gonna you're gonna
go in and you're gonna say yeah you know
what I hate this group and I hate that
group and I love white supremacy and I
am a Nazi
then you then you deserve everything
that comes to you when it when it's the
justice of of either you know the court
of of the public or the court of law and
order well here's the here's the rub uh
because benbee says it right I was I I
know I know I was it says Tony was
correct about tyt yeah I know and
strawberry uh here on YouTube the young
Traders I'm not saying that's what it
stands for but you know some people are
some people are saying some people are
saying in the chat that's what it stands
for but here's I almost I'll tell you if
you like tyt and you don't like when I
speak out against them you're gonna love
it you're gonna you're gonna love it
when you're gonna love it when tyt is
all in for Senator Joe pharmaceutical
Mansion oh my God you're gonna love it
you're gonna love it when he's on the No
Labels ticket and tyt's like this is the
way forward to nominate a president
that's in the pocket of the
pharmaceutical company it's incredibly
great
yeah good luck yeah good luck tyt and
good luck to all the people who said I
was incorrect and I should be attacking
people on the left
what do you think tyt is it's the left
I'm attacking them that's what I'm doing
also I do want to point out just because
you're on the left or on the right right
we've seen people on the right they do
not attack their own I mean very very
few right very few people I mean we've
seen Ann Coulter recently you know could
or rather continue to go after Trump
Poltergeist yeah Poltergeist uh but if
you look at people on the left and
compare them to people on the right you
also have to understand that the main
difference between these two groups is
that the left holds people accountable
in the sense of if you say something you
do something we're going to call you out
the right goes do I need to I don't
think I need to we're all part of the
same cult right so that seems to be okay
you're a Nazi but you're [__] you're a
republican all right that's fine with me
but if you do anything that goes against
people's rights
or just their Dignity of as a human
being or or what they should be you know
able to have access to
like the left is going to do their job
the left is going to call that [__] out
the left is gonna to check you when
you're not being good right when you're
doing something bad when you're not
representing your constituents when
you're not holding up to your promises
the only time people on the right attack
people is when
you know you didn't try to overturn the
2020 election right or you're a certain
group of people that they don't like and
speaking of dehumanizing people that
brings us to our dishonorable mention
[__] this guy Greg Abbott [__] this
[__]
God [__] this [__] now I'm
assuming
what's the reasons why he's the DM
because I I did I you you uh chose the
DM today I'm assuming it's the buoys but
yes it is the buoys because when I was
so last week when I was out of town I
think it was like maybe Friday or
Saturday there was an update that two
people had died
[Music]
in the river because of these buoys
and
it's really becoming something where you
know I'm becoming [__] sick and
entire I'm I'm honestly becoming sick
and tired of of
the lack of of things being done about
this and be like oh no they're just
buoys don't stop [__] freaking out
Gabe you're overreacting they're just
boot dude I've seen comments in line
with people like they're just buoys they
shouldn't be here I mean if you've seen
the uh there's also comments I think
Aaron rupar made a video and I'll try to
find it he made a video that was
highlighting comments from this video
and people were like oh they deserve it
they shouldn't be here all we're trying
to say is that they shouldn't come
across the border and it's like that's
the reaction you have to people dying
and or uh you know being caught up and
injured like very very
badly because of these [__] saw
blades like this feels like something
out of a movie from saw where it's like
do you want to play a game and these
things are [__] rotating in the water
as a as a current is pushing you into it
you want to tell you you might tell you
why they call it a snagging around
yeah sure the intention is to snag you
and pull you under the buoy that's the
intention now you got to remember that
this buoy is sitting in less than five
feet of water right yeah so when someone
walks up to it it's not like they're
swimming to it they're standing in the
water trying to climb over this big ass
bubble as it were veteran Rose now the
reason why they have the saw blade in
between is because that is the best
opportunity for you to crawl through the
buoys now I want I want to say in all
fairness people are calling this a saw
blade this isn't a saw blade where
they're sharpened to be saw blades this
is actually designed to catch you and
pull you down with the buoy okay the the
intention is for these teeth to grab
whatever it can grab and turn with the
buoy as you grab the buoys you're trying
to move through the middle of them and
its intention is to grab snag and pull
you under the buoy drown you know like
in the water here so when this buoy is
in the water like that number one when
the water's low this buoy isn't even
going to work properly anyways yeah so
they're kind of worthless now when
there's the water's not that high and
the reason why is because it has to be
on top of the water not on on the
riverbed to turn Okay has to be on that
to turn but its intention is to pull
people under the water now what is your
intention if you're going to pull people
under the water and hold them there
what's your intention to drown that's
why they call these snagging drowns
um and I can't even believe you know we
listen conservation departments all
around the country conservation
departments would be mortified if they
put these in rivers and and Wild game
were being caught in them and drowned in
rivers they would they would be calling
for people to be prosecuted not not Peta
I'm talking about State conservation
your state has a conservation department
and they can serve the wildlife and the
and everything that is uh go to the go
to the link I sent you this is the one
from Aaron that I was talking about this
is the reactions that people had under
this video that was being shown online
this is the the one that I'm showing
where yeah yeah this is up close yeah
Aaron took a video of scrolling through
the comments and revealing what people
said and this just goes to show you the
type of people that are out there
who instead of being like oh these
people should find a more legal way to
do it these people are not saying that
these people are like no you got what
you [__] deserved you know basically
go home go home you don't deserve to be
here if you're gonna climb across these
then eggs omelets something as long as
there are no signs and as long as signs
in multiple languages like if you go
back down okay no he doesn't want them
to die he wants them to go home
um okay
that man oh wait stop pause it
go back
let's see one says that man Greg Abbott
said he will not stand for any illegal
immigration
you must be like want to play a game
do you see what I saw oh that's a that's
hilarious yeah
eggs omelette something but cluster
bombs are fine
see people who have never seen a uh seen
concertina wire in the parking garage of
an upscale Condo building the Department
downtown area of a democratic City
again so they're speaking to the wire
that's at the the bank of the river in
case they get past the snagit drown
buoys
um so that way so that way they can't
climb on the bank and it and there's
images of people passing infants through
the razor wire
um to get them to safety to the other
side folks this is [__] America I I
want to tell you part of my family has
been here since um the late 17th century
okay and now my other family came in The
Great Migration late in the late 19th
century and they came through an island
out there in New York and there's a
statue of a lady and that lady is called
Liberty and when when my relatives came
through Ellis Island they were welcomed
with open arms because they were
immigrants and because they had
contributions to make to this country
and our country is today because of all
of my and your family members who walked
or who took the boat and came through
to this country for Liberty and for
freedom and to make themselves Americans
and to be part of the American dream as
it once was called
and to think that these people crossing
this border are not looking for the same
the same re the same thing the same
dream that those people who came through
Ellis Island under this with the Statue
of Liberty standing there
the the believe that that these people
are somehow different you are you are
[__] you are a piece of trash that you
think that these people are not looking
for Asylum and not only that but adhered
for the American dream and for what
America stands for which is liberty and
freedom and if you don't think that well
just be an [__] and find out [__]
around and find out how that's going to
work out for you so there's our
dishonorable mention uh it should be
dishonorable murderer for the week yeah
quite honest uh Greg Greg it just goes
to show you how little Republicans
actually care about human life they
claim to be pro-life and save the
children wait what they're totally
famous as long they even acknowledge
life anymore I don't even know they know
that's a good question but I can tell
you right now they're completely fine
with a brown kid drowning because they
shouldn't have been in this country even
though this country is literally built
its foundation on immigrants we left
another country and came here right
granted we stole a lot of the [__] that
was his country from the indigenous
people that were here Oh you mean you
mean like um what's that one country
below us that basically was the entire
Southwest of the United States is it
called Mexico is that it's called Mexico
oh okay yeah yeah I gotcha it's kind of
funny it's just funny yeah it's another
one of those things I mean the United
States would be so much smaller if
Mexico actually had you know
twice the amount of land that originally
had
but hey you know America land of the
opportunity that we have to take
whatever we want whatever we want
however we want
brown kids God forbid you try to cross
the border to pursue a life that is
better an opportunity that is better to
ensure the safety and prosperity of your
family
well according to Republicans you can go
[__] yourselves you can't you can
according to Republicans uh so thank you
Greg Abbott for being the dishonorable
murderer of the week a caretaker on um
the Discord chat is asking wait who is
the alpha cook caretaker are you ready
are you ready oh we got the cuck for you
it's Boris Epstein why is why did Boris
why did Boris make his way on the alpha
guy you know he some people are
postulating that possibly Boris is the
six co-defendant in the January 6th case
some have said that some people like
that some people say that well you know
if you thought the only thing out of
Arizona that was shitty was Gary Lake it
was Perry lake or was uh
Kristen Cinema let me tell you again the
reason that this little [__] turd is
on the alpha cook for bonehead of the
week it's because uh there's footage
that came out of him but he's been
accused of molesting and groping women
at an Arizona nightclub and he continued
reportedly groped her and his woman and
her sister
while they were there this is back in
October of 2021
um and and keep in mind this is the guy
that has been he was there for the
release the Kraken announcement with
Sydney Powell way back to 16. remember
this guy was on the oh yeah on the
goddamn news circuits he was there he
was there on MSNBC and Fox News and CNN
I remember we went on Bill Maher and he
was like he was even there for Donald
Trump's arraignment in New York right
yes he showed up and everyone's like
whoa what's going on over here
the criminal code defendant was and he
was sitting there as a lawyer yeah
because Boris is a is a lawyer and I put
quotes around because you got to do that
with all these attorneys in Trump
Warriors just like Tom fitton is a
lawyer right okay our our Haba is a
lawyer okay yeah Christina Bob is a
large lawyer okay Eileen Cannon is a
lawyer right let's let's see judge right
let's look and see Boris the lawyer here
let's see him lawyer his way out of the
sexual assault that he's committing here
[Music]
okay so if you couldn't hear over the
music because the music's playing in the
background on this video but this woman
is telling this person on camera that
Boris this soprano looking guy that's
hilarious oh my God because he does
totally look like a mobster well he
looks like he looks like Tony Soprano if
you got it from wish.com wow that's
that's not let's not let's not do we
don't want to disarm your name and he
spared the name of Tony Soprano okay
right but let's let's call what it is
he's a wannabe he's a he's he's like if
your family was like oh man my my son's
a big fan of Tony Soprano I'm gonna get
a Tony Soprano impersonator and then he
shows up and he's like hey everybody and
they're like that's not Tony Soprano and
he's like that's the closest thing we
can get off Craigslist right that's it
that's all we got that's all we got here
but this but this uh woman is telling in
real time you see the police officer
standing here too I'm sure the police
officer is making the report that has
led to Boris being on uh the design or
the Outback excuse me because he was
arrested for this but apparently At This
Woman's saying that he was going around
and he was grabbing her and her sister
and he kept grabbing him that I guess
that's what led to her to to report it
he was charged he was charged with a
assault touching attempted sexual abuse
harassment repeated attack acts and
disorderly conduct disruptive behavior
or fighting oh okay so Not only was he
grabbing and then he was fighting with
him and he pleaded guilty [__] a [__]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait are you telling me not only
did he do this but then he went into
open court and pled guilty to this
that's that's what I'm telling you man
oh my God
this is so funny and you know the reason
why this is hilarious and I told you the
the history of Boris here with the
Sinclair uh broadcasting now for these
those of you don't know again Sinclair
broadcasting is a huge corporation it's
owned by a family I forget the I mean
it's Sinclair but I forget the the you
know the it's out of Illinois it's out
of Illinois but they own a lot of local
broadcasting like your local news
station your local news affiliate ABC
Fox NBC who whoever it is maybe it's CBS
they own a lot of those those news
stations that you watch those local uh
broadcast Affiliates and Boris when they
first started buying up all these things
and Trump became president Boris did
propaganda videos pro-trump propaganda
videos I'm not kidding and and he worked
for Sinclair broadcasting and Sinclair
was would force these Affiliates to play
this [__] and Boris was quickly thrown
in the trash because when he started to
do these propaganda videos and I'm not
kidding that's exactly what they were
they were propaganda videos that were
pro-trump propaganda
filtered through Sinclair broadcasting
and what they would do is force those
local uh stations on their local news to
play that segment and people lost their
minds like get this garbage off my local
news like even even people who you would
think be like whoa I can't believe that
they lost their minds that they were
getting fed the propaganda that they
want to hear yeah but the local news
people aren't used to the local news
being fed them just absolute thin veiled
propaganda especially when it's fascist
propaganda like Boris was producing for
Trump when it was just [__] lies even
in my area the the local affiliate that
was bought by Sinclair and they started
broadcasting Boris uh every night or
once a week or whatever the hell it was
they lost their minds and they pulled
him immediately and the Affiliates told
Sinclair no we're not going to play this
garbage no one wants to watch it they're
turning us off so Boris was thrown in
the trash by Sinclair because of this
this is I don't think this is the same
video but this is the one that comes to
mind when we talk about Sinclair there's
one video that I remember specifically
that was that they did a a compilation
to show you
the script that all these local stations
had to read
um and I'm sure people have seen this
and I'm sure you've probably seen this
too but this is the this is the one that
comes to mind that really really gives
you an idea of of how Sinclair works
right and and Sinclair owns these
Affiliates and they're pumping these
these talking points into their scripts
they're forcing these stations because
Sinclair owns them they're like no this
is how you're gonna say it this way
they're forcing The Producers to put it
in to the news
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
exactly
okay well there's your little taste of
uh Sinclair broadcasting oh not
propaganda at all totally totally
independent no no no no Tony they
thought of that stuff okay dude they're
in the news of course they're going to
cover the same stories and of course
they're going to say the same exact
thing I mean that one woman she's like
it's extremely dangerous to our
democracy I'm like okay just act normal
dude just say it normal and don't make
it weird and I I wanna I wanna point out
when that video is from that that tweet
that you sent I just I just retweeted it
yeah it's from April 2nd
oh wait wait wait that's from 2018. not
this April 2nd who is who was was there
a guy president 2018 what was his name
um
I don't know uh well I'm sure if I go
through some court documents I could
find it oh okay well yeah oh it's Trump
that's right okay yeah we'll find out
we'll find out soon enough in the
January 6 trial who the president was in
2018.
oh boy that's why Boris Epstein because
he's a groper who would who would think
that the person who was a campaign shill
for Donald Trump in 2016 the [__]
Grabber would be out in the club
grabbing women by the you know you know
who you know whatever you know
from or whatever you know who would
think that that would be the guy
not me psych right speaking of scumbags
our bonehead of the week this week
Clarence or Clarence clearly
he's for sale
for sale for sale for sale for shell for
shell for sure uh Clarence Thomas you
voted for him to be bonehead of the week
I'm Gabe Sanchez how many millions of
dollars is the reason why Clarence
Thomas is the bonehead of the week I
don't know how many millions of dollars
I do know that 38 billionaires
38 to take clearance out
to dinner are we is that his new
nickname now clearance clearance
clearance
tell your seat to the richest person
available okay well let's get to the
bottom of this
um because uh let's see here here's a
good post Brenda uh you're on Twitter
has it there's 38 destination vacations
around Bahamas boy that sounds really
swell you know what I mean 26 private
jet flights holy [__]
26 private jets do you think yeah uh
hello supreme
Supreme Court of course you're gonna go
private baby so Supreme Court eight
helicopter right you know what I I've
never ridden in a helicopter if this was
my billionaire payoff list I would be
really pissed off that I only got eight
helicopter flights I'm not gonna lie
they're like what the [__] only eight do
you know how long I've been a Supreme
Court Justice and you've only bought me
eight helicopter flights this is
[__] I should have B at least in the
hundreds and so I mean I'd be mad I mean
if I were if I were clearance Thomas I
would request that I get a helicopter
ride from my home right
to the grocery store for that matter
yeah I mean if you're just going to pick
up some milk I mean these are these are
billionaires these are billionaires and
this is sellout City that we're talking
about why only eight he should be very
disappointed you know what I bet I bet
Clarence Clarence Thomas is really
pissed off this morning he's like you
know what you're right it's only eight
Tony God damn it I could add so many
more helicopter flights he's like I want
to renegotiate my contract right
you signed your deal with the devil uh
he's he's gotten tons and dozens of VIP
uh sporting tickets and it's uh I guess
it's college and professional uh he
stays in luxuries Resorts and floor who
would want to stay in a resort in
Florida I'm sorry did I say that out
loud
um is it a leprosy well I mean I guess
if you're going for treatment the
leprosy I hear that they do good
treatment down there but this is just
this is just a small portion of the [__]
that clearance clearance because he's
for sale clearance uh as as Brenda put
here Justice for sale
he's for sale for sure and he likes to
sail
he likes the sale
I think his his wife Jenny Thomas as
soon as I got married she was like you
are gonna be my prized possession and
I'm going to I'm going to flaunt you
around
it's like when you go to like a like a
like a fair you know and they're like oh
this is my prized you know pig or this
is like my prize this or whatever and
you've you know you you kind of [__]
parade them around you know and you're
like yeah look at this one this is a
good one look at how strong he is like
really going back to [__] auction
[__] you know like and and I think Jenny
Thomas really is the one that's
controlling
the people that are buying in to a share
of
of Clarence Thomas well right because
she's the political activist right yeah
again here's here propublica actually
broke this story and here's their post
on it
um it says at least 38 and I say I think
they say at least because they're like
these are the ones we can identify every
day it's a new one they fight right
right 38 like when this originally broke
it was you know Harlan Hitler and it was
like oh look he took him to I spent a
half a million dollars on this guy and
it's like I have a million dollars what
what what what and then we even said I
was like dude the other the other shoe
has not dropped yet and then it was like
a couple days later and they revealed oh
he actually took trips and went to this
private Resort that he owns on an island
and he also took him here he took him
there he took him private jets and I was
like I still feel like there's gonna be
other stuff then you're like oh and then
he bought his clan bought clearance
Thomas's mom's home for him and then he
did this and then he did this and he's
got that one kid that's gonna turn it
into a museum okay yeah oh yeah right
well you know that's the funny part is
proposes he got one standing invite to
an Uber exclusive go what is uberX like
the company Uber or just Uber no it's
just like extreme oh okay okay they own
they're like we never let anyone that's
not white and Rich so but you can have
it if you come in with your chaperone
which is like Harlan Hitler and or other
billionaires then we will let you in
but if it's anyone if it was any other
occasion if you were to come in here and
try to apply on your own we would not do
it how much does uh clearance make
uh each year being it's like 200 and
something about 260 000 340 not two
forty two fifty something like that I
mean it's it's it sounds like a lot of
money at first but really when you no
maybe I'm thinking more oh no that's
sorry wait that's hold on hold on hold
on
along with a few other allowances yeah
because they probably get like stipends
and stuff like that there's like travel
stipends and food stampings right right
and and they probably they probably have
vacations and stuff that they get that
they probably get um yeah paid paid time
anyways the point is this is that the
guy makes uh 230 000 a year now it
sounds like a lot of money and really in
reality it's more than most Americans
make right yeah so you should be living
quote high on the hall compared to most
middle class Americans oh actually sorry
associate justices as of January 2023
make 285 000 so they got in a raise so
again and chief justice gets nearly 300K
right right so the Chief Justice which
is uh the Thomas Roberts gets a little
uh more yeah because he's that he's the
head he's the head uh idiot in charge up
there
um but the other just to get about 280.
now 280 sounds like a lot of money but
really that's it is a lot of money it is
a lot of money but that's but to be
honest that's middle class it's not rich
that's not middle yeah bull [__] [__]
it ain't that is not a middle class
listen listen to me this this is the
thing that makes me mad about this is
that we have been we have been
programmed in this country to think that
poor means middle class that is not I'm
telling you go back and you look at the
cost of things and what things cost when
we had a real middle class in this
country when you could live and you
could afford to support an entire family
in one household on one income and you
go back and you rewind in history what
that amount is it's gonna probably
equate to about 200 250 000 a year
I'm telling you this idea this idea that
somehow Clarence Thomas is Rich off 280
000 is ridiculous he's rich off his
Investments he's rich off all the
political money that his wife sucks up
he's Rich because he gets to do all this
[__] for [__] free and you don't have
to pay for a single goddamn dime of it
he's politically corrupt is the reason
why
clearance is Rich that's okay I would
say that that is upper middle class
right but yes I get it upper middle
class but why can't we strive in this
country
what I'm trying to say what I'm trying
to say is is Thomas is not [__] Rich
because of this salary yeah that he's
not [__] wealthy and Rich because
imagine there Hey listen that is not
going to afford you 26 private jet
flights yeah no [__] way is that
amount of money gonna play for pay for
it might get you 26 first class tickets
somewhere
yes but it ain't going to get you 26
private jet lights I would also uh oh
Mad Max says Clarence Thomas net worth
is 24 million as of wait a second how in
the hell is that possible if he's only
getting paid how is that possible if
he's only he does so many speaking
engagement right Tony right right
but it also must be really nice not to
have to spend money when you're getting
flown around and [__] chauffeured and
you know whined and dined and and making
sure that hey when this case come across
the court you know make sure to vote
this way right
well I mean obviously they're buying
their influence and they're buying I
mean he's for sale so when you expect
someone to be for sale but but but
hunter Biden all right that's five
million dollars I mean it's at 10
because five doesn't sound big enough
wait wait wait wait it's probably 40.
but also we don't need actual evidence
right it's just the implication hey hey
Devin Archer our number one our number
one witness uh for Joe Biden did he do
anything wrong I I don't think so I
never talked to him about no money
oh God they [__] the best I did did he
ever say
that he was in on something did he ever
phone call it's like yesterday you know
uh uh just Fox News though I'll probably
end up doing it what was that this
weekend on it it's just [__] insane
Fox News
it's clear you know they they cannot
they they're hedging their bets in terms
of whatever happens with Trump
um but they're hedging their bets
because they're desperately trying to
avoid talking about Donald Trump's
indictments they can't talk about them
going to court they can't talk about the
indictments so as a result they have to
go against Biden Biden's economy is
actually doing pretty good [__] okay uh
well then we can talk about uh we'll
talk about Hunter Biden and they're
trying to latch on everything they can
to Hunter Biden every segment that I've
watched in the last three days has been
a tie to Hunter Biden and it Jesse Jesse
Waters talking about Joe Biden doing a
Weather Channel interview
and they were like oh when he was
talking about the weather wink wink he
was talking about this and it's like
that's not at all what's happening then
you got Kaylee mcinerney who's talking
about oh Joe Biden was was looking over
notes while he was uh he was reviewing
notes in the middle of this Weather
Channel interview while she also let me
just check my notes oh yeah she checked
her notes while she was making fun of
Joe Biden check his notes because he
wanted to make sure they had the facts
right you know Jon Cryer says it best
here for our bonehead of the week he
says I think there's plenty of evidence
to support that both Clarence Thomas and
Hunter Biden are unethical sleaze bags
gonna step out on lamir and demand they
both resigned
they should both resign from their post
uh
Thomas and Hunter and so there you go
there's uh John there I mean you know
bless James Comer's heart because uh no
he's really trying his darndest right
now he's really trying his darned as
Tony he's going out there on a limb on
the Fox News with Maria
bartacoomo and saying like please please
please please I need you to believe me
that we have proof and every time she's
like so when are we gonna see this stuff
he's like well I hope I hope soon I hope
so maybe now and now they're just like
we don't have it so we're just going to
go forward with it and say we don't need
it hey James maybe you should look at
the evidence that propublica has has
drummed up on your buddy Thomas or you
know what you couldn't do that because
you're probably bought by the same
billionaires oh bonette of the week
clearance Thomas Thanks for
participating let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Justice Thomas you're the bonehead of
the week
no chance for anyone else no one
probably knew who Scooby-Doo was no when
I seen that video I'm like yeah he's got
to go on there and then oh man it got
buried didn't it boom buried with them
now they're like oh no it's not fair we
got a special console that we have again
every single time that anyone in the
documents case has got a special counsel
when they were like okay we're gonna
have a special counsel and they're gonna
investigate we got one for Mike Pence we
got one for Joe Biden
nothing comes back they're like there
was none right and yeah they're like
what about Hunter Biden but in each of
those other ones like there was no
malicious intent there was no desire or
motive to sell Secrets or use them in
some way that was uh against the country
and when those came when those came back
especially when they were like oh look
look we got to search the house we're
gonna find some in this house and it's
like actually we didn't find anything
like oh no he's got documents and Janet
down and it's like no and he he doesn't
he doesn't have anything he doesn't have
it there
which again they've requested the
special counsels on these other ones
because Trump got it well the other
guy's got to get it okay fine we'll play
fair we'll give you the thing and if
there is stuff that proves that they
were working with some motive to sell
Secrets or make money or profit or
whatever
then they'll find it
but then they come back and they say oh
actually there's nothing wrong here they
just mishandled the documents and they
gave them back
they worked with the authorities they
said FBI yet come search the house come
search that property whatever you need
to do to make sure that you get
everything you need
that's the complete opposite of how
Donald Trump handles things he holds on
to everything and says no no no I don't
have it I never had it and they're like
we we know you have it because we
literally have footage of you moving it
and we have a testimony or from
depositions of people who worked at
Mar-A-Lago that say that you took those
things or that you did those things
House Republicans go investigate
every last bonehead investigate all of
them that's been don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after the the little
ditty everyone loves the music bonehead
of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh bonehead of the week
bonehead
pew pew pew it's a three hour episode on
Friday
it happens we could do we literally
could do like six yesterday there was so
much news yesterday I could have done
like a 13-hour stream to be quite honest
with you oh yeah all the clips and [__]
yeah today we can do we could do five
hours just reading off the transcript
from chetkin's hearing this morning
where she's like hey dummy don't say
[__] or I'm gonna kick you in the ass
and she did she really kicked him in the
balls but I but I want to be I want to
be clear about this Shopkin did a lot of
things this morning that um the left are
gonna be super mad about eventually
they're gonna be Superman because I
actually I actually think and and I can
check let's check true social real quick
see what see what has he broken it has
he done it yet um no he has not damn it
and the reason why it hasn't is because
he heard what she said in that hey I'll
let you delay if you keep your mouth
shut
she played that so good oh my God
because folks the one thing you have to
understand about this criminal trial is
it is so important to have this be
not a circus and really be a true
criminal trial of Donald Trump and his
[__] crimes no matter when it happens
if it's before after the election and it
is so important that that he get his
fair trial and that the trial result in
the jury's decision that is so [__]
important and it's not and it's
important to our democracy more than
anything and I think this morning uh
chetkin in her not just in her decisions
but in Her speech and the way she talked
to the prosecutors and not only that to
lauro the defense and she is making it
clear that she is a federal judge over a
federal trial and Donald Trump is the
criminal defendant in that trial period
right period it doesn't matter what else
exists in the universe this is what is
happening in this courtroom and we are
going to act as that is happening in
this courtroom and the statement and
then I'm reading off my phone the
statement that she has says in addition
the more a party makes inflammatory
statements about the case Trump
which could taint the jury pool the
greater the urgency will be that we
proceed to trial quickly I will take
whatever measures are necessary to
safeguard the Integrity of these
proceedings
chutkin is the complete opposite the
complete opposite of Eileen Cannon she's
handling this case and she's been fair
if you can read through the transcripts
and she goes back and forth and she's
like look I don't think the doj should
have a protective uh order over
everything I think there is sensitive
material but I don't think that it's
fair it is kind of ridiculous to say it
is ridiculous to say as a federal judge
to think about it in her in her position
yeah yeah she's hearing the prosecution
saying they want everything protected
and she's like yeah but a lot of the
[__] in there is that the public already
knows but I feel like this is I you know
I I I feel like uh Jack Smith and the
doj are coming into this
like they're they're gonna haggle you
know like we're gonna ask for the
maximum amount of thing here and we're
gonna Whittle it down to something that
is still good
but I think they knew going in they're
like we're not going to get the whole
protective order We're not gonna be able
to suppress and seal everything but
we're going to get something out of it
and we're gonna get it to that Donald
Trump can't be trusted and they
reiterated that again and again and
again through the transcripts of the
hearing where it was brought up like
well we don't trust Donald Trump because
he has a tendency to hold on to material
that he shouldn't have
he has a tendency to blast stuff out
onto onto true social and online and
complain and then use that information
that should be there and it it I can't
wait for Canon to make her decision on
this skiff you know for Trump to open up
a skiff in his bathroom again but um I
also can't wait for them to do a motion
to chetkin for a skiff
that's gonna be hilarious that's gonna
be great one that's gonna be a I wonder
how many documents are in the in the
Mar-A-Lago case I I oh I have no idea
I'm sure it's way more on the January
6th cases oh way more Discovery way I
mean you've got months of events that
are happening right well and and it's so
deep right it's like it's not just
Donald Trump it's so deep and there's so
many they were trying so many people so
many different Communications phone
calls texts emails video photos this and
that like it's a lot of stuff and you
know
and everyone and this goes to show you
for all the people who are like ah
Merrick Garland you're working too slow
this and this and that like you got to
work faster ah why aren't you doing
anything about it you know
a lot of the work and we talked about
this during the actual jansex hearings
a lot of the work was done
by the investigation of that committee
they they brought I mean they gave Jack
Smith and his team a huge Head Start
they were able to go through and say
great we've got cross-references of
these people on these dates we know
exactly who we need to look into there's
stuff that hasn't been made public that
they've uh that they've made mention to
us that we should look into people that
we should uh that we should investigate
uh events series of of uh of of people
meeting together
conversations whatever it might be
they gave them a head start imagine how
long it would have taken if we did not
have that committee now I'm not saying
Jack Smith wouldn't have been able to
accomplish that but he came in and was
like great everything's already
cataloged I've got everything marked up
on them no they deleted all of it yeah
well that's what Trump says
what the reason why is because he
deleted something and that's what's
going to happen here here I mean if he
if he really deleted everything then
then how many more pages was it over 11
million right here's here's the thing
about um the January 6 select hearing
and I actually believe that at this
point Chuck can actually sees the
January select hearings as a hurdle for
her to be a judge because he he they
have access to that information now and
she and she did not say that she was not
going to let him campaign she is 100
gonna let uh Trump campaign but she made
clear this morning in this hearing that
she is not going to put up with him
intimidating witness and tainting the
jury pool for sure for sure for sure for
sure and you know what we're probably
going to talk about this more on our
patreons this weekend I'm sure as more
news comes out about this this afternoon
I know you do a you do a Sunday night
thing as I do a Sunday night thing uh so
you'll be able to go to what was
that.com or what was that show.com
excuse me what was that show.com or go
to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez who
what he's got going on over there and
he'll do a q a this Sunday on his
patreon page and check out mypage
patreon.com Tony Michaels again this
weekend there's gonna there's gonna be a
free membership you're not gonna have
access to everything but you'll be able
to see the page you'll be able to see
what was going on over there uh it won't
be all blind to you so I'm gonna
activate that sometime this weekend and
you'll know and next week I'll I'll
announce it so you'll there'll be free
memberships so you can come follow the
stuff on patreon as the round table of
democracy stuff happens over there we're
going to do a Roundtable democracy here
in about an hour it'll be in about an
hour uh from now I'm gonna do a round
table democracy we're gonna go through
the field team six website we're just
going to take quick tour look and see
what's there make you comfortable about
field team six and texting campaigns if
you don't like to call your
representative you want to text or
something
um so we're gonna go to field team six
and see what that's about so go to
d20michaels.com find the Roundtable
democracy playlist there it'll be
available for every everyone tomorrow
but if you want to participate live go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels also if
you're not in on the Discord it's where
the chat party never stops it'll be all
weekend long on Discord all weekend long
on the Discord so let me let me drop the
um let me drop the link in the chat here
for the Discord because it'll be all
weekend long going going going gone just
like the chat here on YouTube or twitch
or Facebook wherever you're chatting at
also also don't forget we now have venmo
chat venmo chat if you want to send us a
message thanks to Andrea and MJ for
sending us venmo chats today if you want
to send a venmo chat we'll talk about it
live on the show and if we don't get to
your comments live on the show maybe
I'll make a special or gable make a
special social media video answering
your questions if you haven't okay
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify
and Google
don't forget to also go over to Twitch
and renew your subscription on Twitch if
you haven't linked to your Facebook page
follow us on Twitch at Tony Tony
twitch.tv Tony Michaels Jesus Christ
it's Friday folks whew that's why I need
an hour that's why I kind of need an
hour in between now and the I need to
get the editing done I gotta maybe take
a leak and drink some water like a rest
well you know I already did the other
thing earlier
because I know uh this weekend it's
going to create more news and just
because the Republicans are going to say
really stupid things about the news that
happened today with Merrick Garland now
Hunter Biden uh judge checking we'll see
if there's any rulings out of Judge
Cannon this week we'll find out if
there's a trial date that Chuck and a
chucking sets for the January 6 trial
there's going to be so much news coming
I'm telling you you're not gonna You're
Not Gonna Wanna Miss a single thing so
subscribe to the YouTube channel now
watch us every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific two full hours are on Friday
sometimes
three damn hours sometimes it happens
I gotta get Gabe off here so he can go
he can go get his what was that done so
go go check out patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out patreon.com Tony
Michaels have a great weekend be safe
until Monday same time same place surf
sup [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon